I
just blew my nose.
There was a mistake.
Ectoplasm everywhere.
Hi, my name is Bill.
Gochichi tsumoto-sama.
Hello.
Welcome in.
Hi.
I'm taking a break.
I'm taking it in everybody's names.
Hmm.
Yes.
Hello.
It's an every one of you.
I am here.
You are.
I'm here.
Right?
Titan Buncella, the monkey.
Hi.
She's doing roll call.
I'm making sure you're all here.
I'm making sure everybody's here.
Minky time.
Over two years is crazy to be...
You think it's 30 months?
Fake me is at 30 months.
That's insane.
25 months.
Do not perceive.
Quito, minto.
Present.
Hello.
I'm here, I'm here.
You are here.
Thank you, everybody.
Chat is going too fast for Minto to see everyone.
Joke's on you.
I stop the chat so I can read all the names.
And then I can, then I scroll down.
M-I-N-T-O.
T-O.
She's the cutest ghost.
Minto!
The chat is green!
Okay, now it's a little fast.
Minto would never say my name as if i wasn't just literally
reading the letter you delivered to me for from minta with
love earlier guppel okay i was cleaning because i've been
i've been packing from i'm i'm i'm picking up shop i'm going
from one maid cafe to a next and so i've been cleaning and i
was going over i was looking at i was i was reminiscing i
was looking at letters from Framinto with love and I was
reading them and I was like, ah, called out.
Congratulations, thank you!
If anyone asks, I wasn't here.
I literally was reading yours too!
Or goodness, I was reading your letter too!
Framinto with love, that was just two weeks ago, right?
Yeah, just two weeks ago.
Goodness gracious.
Right?
Yeah.
It's totally not almost June.
Ah!
Unfortunately, the Yelp reviews will follow you to the new
location.
What the?
I have glowing reviews all across the board.
Yelp, Google, Google Maps, MapQuest.
Where can you do...
Where can you write reviews?
Glass door Ask Jeeves Yahoo Rate my professor
Reddit Seam Everybody agrees Craigslist Sending this since
my letter keeps getting returned What?
What letter?
Wait, I guess I wouldn't know if it's getting returned
Credit score.
Giving a down boat.
You're giving a down boat on Reddit.
Not to be confused with a down vote.
Wikipedia.
I apparently have a Wikipedia page now.
Like an official Wikipedia page.
I checked out the Gichan Village Mystery when you mentioned
it.
Now I'm caught up.
I know.
It's so good, isn't it?
I have a Wikipedia page.
Let's open this spooky declaration merch.
Gonna totally gonna carry the big plush.
It's so huge.
The big plush in one of those chest baby carrier vests at
the con.
Wait, I need to see it, please.
Please bring her everywhere.
What about a wiki feet, though?
Why two people in a row ask about the wiki feet?
TV tropes on Minky?
Oh, I need to get bigger so I can be a TV trope.
What would my trope be?
Too cute to function.
My Fumo just shipped.
I'm excited.
Yippee!
It's huge.
It's actually, I didn't eat.
I remember when they gave me, I have the sample one.
I remember when they sent it to me and I was like,
room for this i don't have room for this right now her her
big big head is currently holding down a box shut that i
have packed last night yeah it's so ginormous but now we
have tiny minky plushie that i first released now we have
giant minky fumo now next thing i gotta do is an in-between
between size if we're Goldilocksing it we're Goldilocksing
it this one's too small this one's too big and this one is
just right yeah next is even bigger well no I couldn't I
couldn't possibly unless
unless I well I don't know actually I should probably
consult my manager before I ask questions I was going to ask
a question but I'll consult before I ask they might be like
hmm you should not say anything not to risk stuff stuff
Things are cooking, everybody.
Things are cooking.
I just can't talk about them.
I had a stroke of inspiration, you could say, last night.
That I was like, I'm going to do everything.
So I made like 50 different plans last night.
So I'd be cooking a little bit.
hmm yes yes yes um but also i mentioned it that i'm picking
up shop i can i guess i can can talk about this now um next
month i will be moving to a new made cafe officially yuppie
yuppie it was gonna be this month and then i got pushed and
then i was like where am i going what am i doing um i could
talk about it now probably um imagine getting one of those
life-size plushies like a mine i want life-size gangar i
wonder if they'll ever make him he'd just be a big old fat i
gotta i gotta lay on him i want that i want it so bad but um
yeah i'm moving so things will be a little hectic uh for me
in the upcoming weeks i'll of course will be streaming i
will do my best to stream and i will do my best to get
everything taken care of so that when i do move i can
immediately pick up streaming maybe just take like a like a
couple days off to to get internet because you would think
that well actually i guess you wouldn't moving to an
abandoned maid cafe and getting internet again is kind of
difficult because sometimes i have to either use like the
neighbor's internet i hope they have a good internet or i
have to be like oh my gosh have you ever heard of those like
911 calls where they'll be like someone called from this
house but we got Nobody lived there.
You know what?
That's me.
Ask it for internet.
Being like, hello, I went internet so I can stream.
Ghost prank calls.
But, yeah.
Originally, okay.
Let me tell you the very spectacular journey I've been on
with my movie.
Moving Crusade.
I...
Hello Minto and I was like, yo!
Congrats on finding a place.
I hope wherever you head is to is nice and cozy.
Also, I hope good morning Minto's are still morning for me.
They will be!
Yes, I will be in a different time zone.
But streaming will be same time.
Same time, same place.
So don't worry about that.
No matter where I move to, I will always be streaming.
Same time, same place.
Yes, yes, yes.
and good morning mintos will still be time they will be time
um uh so shocker oh my gosh who would have imagined minto
was i was originally like for many many months i was
planning on moving to japan oh my god who would have
imagined you know going back and forth i was like going back
and I was trying, I was checking, you know, checking stuff
out.
I was looking at places.
I know.
Shocker.
Wow.
But unfortunately, another ghost wants to take over this
maid cafe.
I don't think it'll be a maid cafe anymore.
Probably just a regular abandoned place.
And I am, I must leave.
And my approval for Japan did not get approved.
in time so um i couldn't i literally was just like in
absolute limbo being like oh my gosh because if i moved to
japan i was going to be using a whole different moving
service i was having to take care of a bunch of other stuff
this and that so um uh you know i kind of was just twiddling
my thumbs for a really long time yeah it's a bit of a bummer
but at the same time i'm you know after life happens and i'm
i'm actually i found a really really nice maid cafe i'm so
excited to haunt it i'm very very excited too so um uh if if
my approval ever gets approved i could always move so there
might be multiple moves in my future but um Yeah, all you
can do is all you can do.
What do you mean, Japan denied their princess?
I know.
How dare.
But, yeah.
So, I'm super duper excited.
The only thing that I need to check is internet.
But I heard it's okay.
Mold free, right?
I believe so.
Hmm.
so um yes uh even if i had moved to japan i was still a
hundred percent just going to stream in the mornings and
have it still be the same time that i stream now um so even
if i do end up moving to japan don't don't worry it will
still be it will still be same you know i wasn't gonna
change that or anything either uh moldy internet no Yeah, so
it'll be a bit of a hectic time for me.
I feel like this entire year has been so hectic time for me.
But thank you guys for being so patient with me and
supporting me.
I appreciate so much.
Yeah, it would have been 8 a.m.
for me to stream.
But that's okay.
I wake up early in Japan usually anyway.
So I don't think it would have been an issue.
I know it wouldn't have been an issue.
I would have waken up, streamed, go to idle lives, go to
sleep, wake up and stream.
Honestly, it works better not streaming at night because
that's when the idle lives are.
That's when the idle shows are.
So I would have had more motivation to stream in the morning
so that I could go to the shows at night.
It's so true.
Eat, sleep, idle live, repeat.
No, eat, sleep, stream, I don't lie, repeat.
You would have had a morning minto.
You would have had me be like, hello guys.
Every time, can you imagine though, after like every stream,
my morning voice being like, hey guys, I just woke up.
A good morning minto.
I think I would have gotten confused though.
I feel like when I'm in Japan, I guess.
I can never remember what time it is in my current time.
So I never, I do have a spoker voice.
Crispy Minto.
Yeah, I wouldn't have a nice lubricated voice for you all.
A nice, nice, hold on, let me get real close to the mic.
A nice voice that has been properly, had water and stuff.
golly yeah my buttery smooth voice that everybody always
everybody is always saying her voice is so buttery smooth
yeah congrats on moving to an offshore oil platform boss I
want that can we all just move to an offshore oil rig
together and then we could put posters of me up around you
could steal them for points I'm in we can have our own we'll
make our own place outer heaven that's literally outer
heaven for me can we live in dredge why dredge is not a oh
wait the dredge does have the oil rig doesn't it
yeah yeah my nice sure yippee our only One-made cafe?
Yeah.
Does anyone know how to fly a helicopter?
Oh, we're taking applications.
Right now.
Send it to me.
Ibu Sans Frontiers.
The boat life.
Oh, my gosh.
We could all get matching stickers that say salt life or
slut life, whichever you prefer.
That's kind of how I always read those stickers.
Have you guys ever seen the salt life stickers?
some people have on their cars if you if you are in the u.s
maybe you have seen them but i always read them a slut life
and you can pick your fancy you can say i'm a salty or i'm a
slutty little i boo yeah you are you freak i sometimes i see
the stickers like out in the middle of nowhere way you have
a salt life there's no way you are you are landlocked buddy
i give it all up to fight for you boss wait who are we
fighting who are we fighting can we be sweet yeah
this is the midwest my god i yeah i'm salt keeping right now
Unless they're just like really salty, you know, like, I
play Valorant.
Salt life, buddy.
I play Starcraft.
Woo, salt life.
League players, yeah.
Wait, does anybody play Starcraft anymore?
I don't even know.
Called out.
Salt life equals League of Legends player.
Whoever you tell us to, boss.
No, no fight, no fight.
No fight, no fight.
As someone in Florida, hope you can come to home out again.
I'd love to!
The salt life stickers and decals are everywhere.
I can't even argue it's the wrong state for that phrase.
That's true.
That's so true.
It is the right state for the salt life.
Yeah.
I guess, yeah, Florida makes sense.
What else makes sense?
Florida.
Would you have to say that?
I feel like it's such a Florida phrase.
I wouldn't even give it to California.
You know what I mean?
Anything coastal.
Florida just feels right to be the salt life headquarters.
Florida has water on three sides.
Wow, we have a mathematician over here.
My first thought was...
My first thought was the Jack Black octagon octagon octagon
stop sign has eight sides octagon he can count the three me
too me too salt life Michigan no no actually you know who
else I would give a clearance to use salt life stickers the
joysie shore i think that place too deserves it do tell
the exit was that pretty good was that good was that all
right i live in joysie and never been to the shore what are
you doing what are you doing you have to go i've even been
to the joysie shore and then I almost drowned there.
Luckily, I'm a ghost, so.
But I went for a good old tumble in the waves.
Be careful if you go there.
They try to kill you.
That beach is out for blood, I think.
Hmm.
Mm-hmm.
I think so.
At which beach?
I don't know.
I just remember...
I went to the beach and I tumbled in the waves real good.
I was like, whoa, I don't know if I'm making it out of here.
But then I went to mini golf and I saw everybody loves
Raymond.
And I didn't know who that was.
I only knew that I saw him because my dad and my papa were
like, everybody loves Raymond.
Yeah.
Ray Romano, Ray Romano.
Yes, yes.
He was mini-golfing.
You could also see a washed-up sitcom celebrity if you go to
the Joisey Shore.
So I recommend it.
Everybody should go.
Is his name really Ray Romano?
There's no way.
I almost drowned in a wave pool once.
Does that count?
Yeah, I'd say so.
Let's see.
Oh, Ray Romano.
Ray Raymond.
What's his name?
Ray Raymond?
No.
Ray Romano.
Ray... Wait, now it's saying including results for Ray...
Oh, I put Ray Ramono.
Wait.
Ray Romano.
Oh, there's... Oh.
Ray...
Ray Mono.
Um, let's see.
Hmm, this guy's real name is...
Raymond Romano!
Oh my god.
No way.
Is this who I saw?
I guess so.
I don't remember what he looked like at all.
Vint is having a stroke.
A little bit.
The heck, even he...
That's his normal...
No.
Why is his...
name wait everybody loves raymond wait what's his name
what's every yeah why is it named after him ratoria roman
hey minke i finally overcame my fears and got my driver's
license today a decade and a half late my teeth only chatted
for half the test congrats k born it's okay i also waited
until i just before I died to get my driver's license.
And so it was a couple years, too, for me.
And when I did my test the first time, I had to take it
twice.
When I did my test the first time, I drove on the wrong side
of the road.
I drove on the left.
And I didn't even make it out of the parking lot.
They were like, they were like, they were like, nope, no
more.
Go back.
You fail.
failure.
Go back, you stupid failure.
And so, yeah.
Proof that you were a Japanese princess.
I was following my blood.
I was following my instincts.
I failed my first time, too.
I do agree, though, that they should make people retake the
test.
Every, like, not, like, super often.
Like, five years maybe like eight years i think people
really need to retake the test it's okay you'll be driving
on the correct side of the road in forza horizon six yeah i
saw some i you know i was just like you know what maybe i
will play after somebody mentioned it on stream the other
day i was like yeah i'll drive car around around japan so 10
years 15 years five years feels too often Maybe.
Are you Japanese Hime or are you British?
I'm British?
Someone alert the queen!
A new Brit has been discovered in an undisclosed location.
Is saying Brit okay?
I said it again.
Am I being offensive?
yeah it's fine okay good you can't just say that I'm gonna
get cancelled I'm gonna get cancelled every time I say that
I'm gonna get cancelled I think of this one girl that went
on I don't think it was America's Got Talent it was like uh
not the voice it was what maybe American Idol or something
and she goes on and she's got like this super monotone like
her eyes are like this and she's just like okay i'm gonna
sing my song now and she goes she goes i used to have wait
how did it go she's like i used to have a pet i don't
remember lizard or something i used to have a pet lizard and
i gave it to my mom and she was really happy because lizards
are really cool and then the rest of the song this is her
audition by the way this is like her trying to get on to
american idol and this is what she sounds like exactly right
and then the rest of the song is they try to cancel me
cancel me bother me bother me and then she goes babies shut
the up carons shut the up parents shut the up
Uh, rent.
Shut the fuck up.
Um, uh.
Uh.
A banger.
As a resident Brit, I give you the Brit pass.
Yippee!
But yeah, that was just the whole song.
Truth nukes.
I literally spit in bars.
Her name is Sophie Powers.
Thank you.
Sophie Powers.
I recommend the clip, it's funny.
When are you covering it?
I did just now.
Ryazaki, welcome back!
Thank you!
I don't know Sophie Powers, I just know the clip.
Relation to Austin?
Great, great, great, great, great, great descendant,
probably.
25 months of Minto feels like yesterday!
I know, I was just...
i was i was thinking the other day i was like i need to
start planning for my for my six year anniversary i have
been streaming in two months i will have been streaming for
six years
good i'm i'm all i'm old and washed up now you guys are all
gonna forget about me i'm gonna look at the new shiny
twinkling thing Oh, she is six years old!
I'm in kindergarten!
Washed up.
I'm washed up.
Never.
Won't you?
You promise?
Yeah.
We'll be old alongside you.
Vampire do it.
Welcome to Mamba- Virgil.
Virgil.
Welcome to Mamba-Shell!
Baby Gord, thank you so much for the gift!
Thank you.
You're our old dusty ghost.
Oh, thank you for not adding crusty.
Dusty, crusty, washed up, shriveled up.
Turned into dust ghost.
Weep cake, thank you.
Okay, Sintai, welcome back.
Morka, welcome back.
I've only been here for one and a half years, so you're new
to me.
Yippee.
love hags yeah oh my gosh speaking of i was on a really long
call with matara today we were catching up like we were
talking about lots of stuff maybe some things that we plan
on doing together so
old but gold if i can't grow old with minky i'm gonna be
forever meow forgot to wear my knee brace can you scold me
dr thundersleeper what were you doing you that you don't
trip and die!
You need to wear your knee brace right now.
How dare you not wear it?
Pinto Stinko has never washed.
Wait, what were we talking about?
Lucky your timeless ghost we can blink and another six years
go by.
2032, here we come.
That's too scary to think about.
Of Miss Red, Trader Joe's is super nutty.
Oats is super slutty Oats.
did she tell you i love you like a wife no
six year anniversary in two months and four four four k soon
it goes so welcome back thank you i discovered you last year
and i think i'll likely be watching your streams until my
eyes eventually give up thank you maddie i held that i You
know, people often discuss like the boom of VTubers, the
trend of VTubers.
Oh, how will they last, this and that?
I hope that, you know, I hope that, like in my opinion, not
as a professional, just as somebody that enjoys
entertainment, I would hope that like people that see
VTubing as like, as like a fad.
How do I say it?
Like, all it is is just entertainment, like a different form
of entertainment, right?
So they say it as much as any other streamer.
Yeah, like, I would hope that you could see me as just like
a streamer.
As someone that like you put on when you're like, oh, you
know, I need something to watch while I'm eating dinner,
while I'm cleaning or something, something, you know?
So I would hope that
V-Tubing would only die if streaming as a whole does.
That's what I think, too.
Yeah, it's just another streaming medium.
So, you know, I would love to do this for until I feel like
I am over my regrets and sorrows and compassion.
But, I think, you know, it would be, it's like, I don't
know.
my girl playing game so you're good you're good you're good
i'm good a minto a day keeps the voices away i am the voice
what if i am the voice on your head don't go into the light
minto no let's go i love you people love the doom and gloom
yeah don't let it get you down like uh if anybody is like
you know if you ever see that kind of discourse just you
know i always say this but just kind of you know if you do
if you like what you like that doesn't matter if it's a fat
or not i just like what you like and do what you do i think
i forgot to take my medicine today oh
um wait a second i'm about to go do that
my meds my meds take your meds it's such a big pill it's so
annoying to take it's caught in my throat okay I'm gonna go
get it real quick I'm gonna cut it in half I've never been
good with peels peels here okay I'll take my peels and then
my my single single single and then i will play game since
it's almost been 40 minutes of me just yapping in the dark
me yapping in silence wait if i click on the game oh there's
no music anyway so whatever okay i'll be right back could be
a suppository i've never had to take one raise your hand if
if you've ever had to take a suppository.
Do they like even, how far up do you have to stick it in
your butt?
But also, do they even prescribe those anymore?
Like, not as an adult.
As a kid though.
Wait, some of you are raising your hands, how painful.
They aren't that bad, really?
As a kid.
When I was a kid, I think, oh my gosh.
I wonder if I accidentally, Not accidentally.
What if I never knew that I got something on my butt?
Oh my god.
Decently up there.
Really?
Ask your parents.
It's like a blacked out trauma from...
How would you know?
Check it now.
It melted now.
Oh, silly.
It dissolves fast.
Oh, those potent juices.
Jess, thank you.
For people that still don't get it, I say imagine Muppets,
but with anime girls.
You'll love it.
Yeah, anime is still popular, so.
Hi, Doc.
Don't call them that.
Okay, sorry.
Muppets?
Or just...
I gotta take off the mitts!
I'll be right back!
I'm back with my split pill, but one split bigger than the
other.
The absolute aura.
Wait, was I smug?
It's my default face.
Okay, now I have to take these.
I'll do the big one first.
Welcome back, thank you!
Wait, did I change the latency?
Let me double check.
La la la la.
I did, okay.
La la la.
Okay, alright.
Big gulp.
Okay, second one.
She's being waterboarded!
Okay.
Shall we play this game forbidden solitaire?
I can't do big peel so I sympathize.
Yeah, it was, it's so huge.
But also when I, when I, when I, when I cut it in half, and
I cut it in half, it makes the edges sharp and it scares me.
I'll tell Steiner to hide them in a block of cheese.
I literally mean kitty but it's forbidden I I'm really
curious about this game because it seems oh just just a
heads up it did have like a like an epilepsy warning for
some flashing lights at the very beginning so just a heads
up on that um that front uh but um I'm quite curious about
this because it's supposed to be like you get it's it's like
you get the CD-ROM that's cursed So it's very 90s, early
2000s coded.
And I saw the demo.
I didn't realize the full game was out.
I haven't played the demo either.
So did it have an etchy warning?
No.
I wish.
Love the concept.
Yeah, I'm really interested in how it...
Oh.
We have Will Roberta.
Oh, it's 2019.
Oh.
Oh, I'm on my co-
Emily Roberta Lol, okay, going to sleep now for real this
time See ya, bro Emmer's Remember that weird violent card
game that mom saw on TV when we were kids The one she made
us promise we wouldn't play Well, guess what I found while
thrifting I'm gonna try installing it when I get home Wish
me luck Oh, and naturally, don't tell mom Winky Oh my god,
dude, no way You found a copy of Forbidden Solitaire I
remember wanting to play it so bad when I was little.
You gotta let me borrow it after you're done with it.
Extremely jealous right now.
Yeah, this is a bit of a spoopy game, allegedly.
There's like a copyright down here.
Like, what can I click?
Can I mess with this Wi-Fi?
Can I turn off the computer?
Wait, I'm guessing this actually shuts down, like, the game.
What's our stats?
Oh.
Wow, wait, this is cool.
win zero total deaths oh is it is it a roguelike solitaire
more like solitaire oh no not solitary i forgot about that
what's my settings oh there's literally a thing for jump
scares oh gosh wait that's scary wait oh uh subtitles okay
hold on content warning Ah!
Oh.
It opened up a link.
Whoa, it's telling me everything.
CGI depictions of bloody corpses.
CGI depictions of biting into flesh.
Catabolism!
Oh my gosh.
Tutorial full... Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
This is fun.
Messages.
Who else do we have?
Oh, just my sister.
More games.
Oh, click the more games button.
Ancient enemy.
Oh, this is the devs.
They need the home safety hotline.
I've been wanting to play this too.
Newsletter.
Oh, opens literally to their website.
46 minutes and like what, five minute in game.
Oh, oh, I don't want to join Discord.
I just did not read that as Discord.
Okay, it's opening all these things on my computer.
I feel like I'm getting viruses.
Home safety hotline is good.
Okay, we can try playing that one next time.
Forbidden Solitaire.
Heartblade Interactive.
Oh.
They say that there is a secret to defeating death.
Really?
I wish I had.
Somewhere beyond the Blood Rock Mountain and through the
dead, I'm getting like...
There it lies.
Known only by legend as the forbidden dungeon.
Oh, what was that GameCube game I played?
Oh my gosh.
It is said that any soul daring enough to plunge its
depths...
Druids, yeah, very druids.
To immortality in the heart of its deepest chamber.
Eternal darkness!
Yes, yes, eternal darkness.
The question is...
How badly do you wish to live forever?
Meow forever and ever and ever.
Forbidden meow.
I want to be forbidden meow.
Woo!
Oh my god.
Far gone, far gone, far gone.
Sansouloul, I got to membership back here.
Santa.
We're playing a Forbidden Solitaire.
Whoa.
No game.
They nailed, they nailed like the aesthetic of it.
I thought it was Limbo of the Lost.
I'm going to play that.
I'm going to play Limbo of the Lost.
I'll get it.
I'll get it working eventually someday.
This is actually taking me back to the 1990s.
Yeah, they did a great job.
You approach the steps of the forbidden dungeon as it looms
over you, waiting for its next victim to willingly enter its
labyrinthian jaws.
Step by cautious step, you approach the entrance.
As you reach out to open the old wooden door, you find it
pulls back against you, locked for the betterment of man's
kingdom.
Not for long.
Oh, solitaire!
One thing I kind of want to play recently is LA Noir.
Isn't that game like super long or am I crazy?
It's fun.
I hope after this you check out the other weird indie game,
Creepy Redneck Dinosaur Mansion 3.
Oh yeah!
It's like 20-ish hours.
Oh, that's not that bad.
You must clear all the cards on puzzle levels to proceed.
Click on the card one number higher or lower than the card
at the bottom of the screen.
Okay, so...
Three.
Then it would be full.
But does it have to be...
Can it be diamonds, though?
Oh, it can.
Okay.
Five.
Four.
Draw a stock card.
There are no more playable cards, so you need to...
I need to draw a new card from the stockpile.
Oh, wow.
What an interesting solitary method.
Is peak historical accuracy?
Eloi Noir.
Eloi Noir is long, but might be your bag.
Check Nimi for how long it took her.
Oh, okay.
I will check her.
Thank you.
It's Pyramid from Neopets.
The only thing I...
Well, I did actually...
I played a lot of games on Neopets, but I played cheat.
Like crazy.
I was I was always cheating on cheat I was a biggest cheater
ever you could have had me on that show cheaters and they
would have been like what's your what's your story and I'm
like them pets never saw it come in I I ruled the cheat
world in my brain
ace number one can go on a king and vice voice wait can I do
like the same card though, like...
Ah!
You started a combo by playing six cards in a row.
Keep combos going to generate mana.
Do you guys say mana or mana?
So it is solitary for real.
You are solitary now.
Click end combo when you need to draw a new card.
Combo, combo, combo!
I need to end my combo.
Make your first combo.
Oh wait, I think I'm...
Wait, no, I think I messed up.
Uh-oh, I messed up.
I messed up.
Oh, no!
Wait, okay, there we go.
Potato, potato, tomato, tomato.
Now you're just saying potato and tomato over and over
again.
Onward.
Finally, the door gives away to your sorcery.
within blinded by the darkness yeah the spark you light your
fingers like a torch illuminating the room with a dim light
a dark maze of stone surrounds you in the distance you can
hear a faint groan dash on my tummy why was there a spooky
guy there oh no it's him you walk towards the source of the
agony and soon see before you a poor crying soul impaled
upon a bloody spear surely you can spare a moment to free
them from their misery Oh.
I thought we were gonna have to play solitaire to do that.
With a slight struggle, you pull the spear from their belly
and they collapse onto the floor.
As you turn to leave, you suddenly feel a horrible pain in
your foot.
Oh, he's chopping on me!
You look down and see this agonized creature has hungrily
sunk its teeth into your ankle.
You realize with horror, this is no man you have freed but a
cannibalistic beast!
Oh.
Versus.
Wait, what?
Fight!
Clear cards to increase your damage.
Then click enter.
Hover over the enemy's next action for detail.
A painful bite that causes...
Oh.
You've reawakened my obsession with this game.
I'm gonna do some digging when I get home.
If I'm lucky, maybe I'll find it on Abandonware.
an abandonment site or something.
I blame you for any slash all digital crimes I may or may
not commit this evening.
Sister!
I forgot that we were on my computer.
Um.
Oh, why did I do that?
I'm such an idiot.
Oh my gosh.
Wait a second.
I'm not.
Is there an undo button?
I'm gonna get painfully bit.
No!
I'm gonna get bit.
Opening Discord on stream.
It's all my sister's fault!
Ouch.
Let's try this.
Oh, we're so screwed.
We are so screwed.
Ouch.
Okay.
This is fine, everybody.
Let's do the king.
And we'll do the queen.
Wait, she doesn't unlock anything else?
Oh my god.
Can I do another queen?
No.
Okay.
Wait.
Refresh tabloid.
cards then attack and then turn this is what microsoft calls
try peak solitaire in their solitaire game home safety
hotline is also very good and spooky too felix thank you for
so much for the pink thank you oh my gosh it really is six
seven i end my turn okay
okay this is good this is good four okay we did a good combo
maybe so So do I need to attack?
Do I do...
It didn't tell me.
Base damage 5.
Like, it hasn't taught me how to attack yet.
I'll wait until it tells me.
This game is what is wrong with E-E all this time.
I think you attack when you enter.
Oh, I think you're right.
He's resting.
Oh, so this is his health.
And this is my...
Ah!
Naruhudo.
I understand, though.
I don't have an 8, do I?
Meow.
This is so stinky.
This is learning.
I'm learning.
Ouch, ouch.
My base damage is 0.
Yikes.
Boing.
10.
9.
8.
Not!
Oh, click refresh to deal new cards when you run low.
This will attack ending your turn.
Combo!
Oh!
We did big damage.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
We just have to clear this, right?
Or we kill him.
Oh, okay.
I thought it was clear the board to...
Okay, never mind.
We're so good.
Ew!
You stand over the creature's unrecognizable corpse, having
overcome the first of the Forbidden Dungeon's many dangerous
trials.
You hear a strange voice coming from a nearby wall.
Turning around, you see an eye peering out from behind a
missing brick.
I can help you.
Gotta clear the board for puzzles.
I'll get it.
Very cautiously, you approach the voice.
Oh.
What is this?
Who's the cutest here?
Don't you roll your eyes at me, mister?
Oh, what is this?
Oh, temporal light.
Click to learn more.
It allows you to undo.
Oh, undo one action per hand.
Price is sick.
Okay, I have 90 gold.
Bloodstone.
Ooh, increases health.
10.
Well, I cannot get that, but I will take it undue.
Oh!
What happened to your other host's dainty hands?
Look, I can't always be possessing the same person, okay?
They get suspicious.
Some days I just have to be a hairy man, alright?
I'm sorry.
It can't be helped.
My hairy Oshi.
This wall chap has a great eye for cuteness.
Mm-hmm.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Yippee!
As we all do.
Yeah?
The same hands I got.
What if I'm possessing you right now?
Ah!
And, and, and, and, but, thank you so much for all of it to
get to take you!
And, oh, is that Ushiro from Clarence?
an ad as your profile picture such good taste oh i was gonna
say i think that youtube is um or rather they were changing
like prices and stuff they keep reminding me about it every
time i like go to do something they're like by the way the
prices are changing for measureships blah blah so i'm trying
to figure out a way that maybe i could lower the price um
what are they right now Hold on.
It won't let me check.
Like maybe I can lower them to like 99 cents USD.
But I'm trying to make sure that I can do that.
I'm trying to make sure I could do that.
So, wait, how do I say?
Without like kicking everybody out.
This game gives mist vibes, maybe.
Yeah, a little bit, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mist, oh boy.
I'm gonna get stuck in the book.
Does this mean you do body mods out of curiosity and shift
to a new body?
I know, I wouldn't.
I would never...
Just don't check your behind for any, like, tattoos or
anything.
What do you mean kick everybody out?
Oh, I don't...
Like, uh, like kick everybody out of memberships.
Because sometimes if you change membership things, they...
it will like...
It will make people leave.
Or like, it'll like, it'll like reset it, you know?
So...
Look at the membership!
Make it higher instead!
No!
I know things are... I know times are tough for people
and...
If you want to support me, I really appreciate it.
But I don't want anyone to feel like they have to go out of
their way to do so.
Yeah.
You could add higher and lower tiers.
Well, it's like, if people gift memberships, I think it like
defaults to the higher tier.
And I would hate that even more here before I get kicked
out.
Yeah.
Vint is currently 199 pounds for you.
And the average is $4.99.
But I think it's going to change.
I think that number is going to change.
It picks the closest to five.
Ooh.
Super liminal.
Thank you so much for the 10.
Get that.
Like, I make enough.
Even if I change it to lower, I'll totally be okay, you
guys.
Remax, thank you so much for the 10.
I don't know why you guys are yelling at me that it's cheap.
I also don't get around to membership streams as much as I'd
like to anyway, so...
You know.
I try to post little sneak peek things if you ever are
curious.
Invisible Mist!
Thank you so much for the...
But yeah.
Thank you!
Oh, Kurama, thank you so much for the thank you, dude!
A hundred dollar a month win.
Whimsy, thank you for the win!
Ah!
Why is everybody gifting all of a sudden though?
Stop it!
Whimsy, thank you!
The encore, thank you!
T-cop, thank you!
Sushi, thank you!
Digital Canary, thank you!
That's a greater thank you!
over here if they are welcome to membership.
Miko, fine, welcome back.
Thank you.
Masashi-ke, welcome.
No, welcome, thank you.
Ah, she did nothing, thank you.
Oh my God, stop.
Stop, thank you.
Navarro, thank you.
Spike, thank you.
Grago, thank you.
Moze, thank you.
Easy tori, thank you.
Easy toos.
Toos, toos, toos, toos.
I joined to support you, not for a member stream.
okay i'll leave i'll leave the prices i don't know i was
just trying maybe i can make a smaller tier though that's
just for emotes or something i don't know
oh my god wait oh my gosh there's so many stop you guys stop
i can't keep up thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you welcome back sent a little camper Welcome back!
Game Boy, thank you!
Hi, Ben, thank you!
Cashmoney Robot, thank you so much!
Thank you!
Hearton, welcome back!
Oh, I'm out of hand here!
Welcome back!
I'm out of hand, I'm out of this dog!
Thank you!
All right, thank you!
Welcome back!
Phil, thank you!
Thank you!
Oh, thank you!
We're killing you!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Did I get all of them?
No.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's actually so many.
Ah!
I heard these are free.
Oh, no!
No, we are not doing!
We are not doing this!
Usapaymos!
No!
No, I learned from Vicky.
They are not free!
These Supas are not free!
I have to do a British accent just so we...
Is that British accent?
free the super's are not free they'll never be free it will
deduct from your bank account thank you let's see thank you
so much for that I'll go soon thank you guys thank you holy
cow where did I leave off on wait it won't even let me
scroll up that much shut up wait no I didn't get to thank
everybody
Will, thank you so much for the tiny e-fukuro!
Thank you!
Danny, thank you!
Carl said thank you!
What happened to Tsuyoi Neko?
Why'd you remove your last name?
Did you get married?
Bianchi-do!
Thank you!
Hi, Minky, hello!
Toki-toki!
Thank you!
No escape!
Tiss himself, thank you!
Don't you guys want me to play the game?
What is happening now?
The gift is will continue to me.
is through the roof.
Just wanted to comment.
Thank you so much for the fatigue.
Welcome back, everybody.
Thank you, Orthworm.
Thank you.
Wee, no free.
No free, no free.
Oh my gosh.
I can't even keep up.
I'm trying.
I'm actually, I'm trying.
I can't keep up.
Wait, did I, did I, uh...
No, well, thank you so much for the fatigue.
Bjorn, thank you.
Mercurially, thank you again!
Oh my gosh.
Am I caught up?
No, I'm not at all.
What am I saying?
Ah!
The offshore rig is gonna blow.
What do you mean?
No game, just resupply.
No!
I'm gonna...
Stop it!
Stop!
This is my birthday today!
Blue Tears!
Happy...
Birthday!
Happy birthday!
Sorry if you heard that, that was me hitting my mic
connection.
I'll just use it as a right offer?
Charity!
Am I a charity case to you?
Mother Base funds?
Lumin, thank you!
Wait, oh gosh, it won't let me scroll up anymore!
Digital Canary, thank you!
I'm still getting my first ever Supa and it's free!
That's it!
I'm playing the game!
Happy birthday, thank you so much for that gift.
Thank you guys, thank you for the gift to everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will post another sneaky peekie in members as a thank you.
I will thank you for the art!
Minto Quito tags, moving parts.
No!
Sipas are free, trust my dad works at Nintendo.
I'm what my uncle works and he said the opposite!
He said they cost double!
With throwing money?
Shaded Octanex, thank you for the focus of...
Lego Gengar, Fudge.
Lego Gengar?
Also for bullying me too.
RJ, thank you for the No game only soon, but no, I want to
play the game.
I want to play the game.
You got old news from your uncle.
Oh, was that last week?
Okay.
Thank you so much, everybody.
I will post a sneak peek on members for everybody that
donated.
I said, thank you.
I already posted a sneak peek, but I'll post another one.
But I feel like I'm going to give away my whole new model at
this point.
Thank you!
Thank you for that, because I don't know what gets into you,
some of you guys some days.
You get, like, an itch to spend money.
Actually, I get that itch, too, though.
I'm going to buy so many clothes.
I have a bunch of clothes for my favorite brand.
I'm in a shopping cart at this moment.
Not lost.
Welcome to Bamboo Shave.
Wait, they cost double?
Let's go!
No!
It never ends.
You guys, we have to...
Maybe the game is forbidden because you forbid me from
playing it because I'm stuck thanking everybody for all of
the super chats.
But for real, don't feel like you have to, especially if you
cannot.
And also, some of you guys, I really worry about your...
Actually, a lot of you guys, I really worry about your
wallets.
New model money, yes!
Oh!
Alright.
Not a joke, YouTube has been offering free first month
memberships.
If you haven't gotten one, click join to see if it's
offering.
Really?
Wait, that's huge.
If you wanna join.
Trying to get more people to do memberships.
I love spending money.
No.
I heard Glee Supas.
Glee?
No game, only Supas.
Ow!
Also, that one dead guy.
I think your don't know will be stuck in in the hells of of
membership gifts so thank you so much for the Haka don't
know Supas may not be free but stream labs are free and cut
out YouTube fees that is true Apple thank you gifts are free
so gifted subs too no fire eater welcome back speaking of
money when do I get a refund for my Wisp license plate.
No!
Keep it, please!
Unless you change the Ibu, that is fun too, though.
There's free Supas to add to the Minto clothes for now.
Thank you.
Thank you, babon.
This is officially turned to Supa Stream.
No!
I'm going back to the game right now.
Thank you, Dreadnought.
Thank you!
Let's get back to the game, everybody.
We must go through the dungeon so we can achieve
immortality.
Gathering your strength, you stumble back into the darkness.
I'm going to forget how to play the game at this point.
Step by step, you walk down the dungeon's many cold stone
halls.
Faint torchlight guiding you, or perhaps deceiving you.
Right now, I live in my parents, so while I look for a new
place to...
No!
That's even more money to save!
What's... No!
That's even more money.
to save you have to save for your moving funds i wish i
could refund you guys sometimes especially because someone
if you are here you know who you are someone sent big dono
off stream three times in a row thinking that it didn't go
through i felt so terrible because there's no way for me to
refund that I was like, no.
That felt so bad.
Because I saw it happening.
And I was like, oh no, how do I stop this?
How do I stop this?
No, they definitely didn't do it on purpose.
I felt so bad, though.
I almost, it was like, I should start stream so that I could
be like, I received your donation.
Please do not donate anymore.
I'm like, please, because it was like the same message three
times in a row.
So whoever, if you are watching this, I did see.
And I felt really, really bad.
I felt so terrible.
12-second stream to save them.
Truly, truly, truly.
I felt so bad.
Can't afford my dog's funny bone surgery.
Honeybone surgery.
Anyway, free shupaj.
Just bought a house, so I'll use this free one.
It's not free, but thank you, W.C.
This.
You turn around, not recognizing the path you took.
Where are you?
You hear groaning in the distance.
You must find the way forward.
With haste.
Search the dungeon.
Oh.
no luck on any of the pirate sites.
I guess some parent groups made it their holy mission to
destroy as many copies as possible, so it's rare now, dude.
You should rip that shit and upload it.
Preserve it for the good of gaming.
Yeah!
Was playing Forza Godfrey's super no!
I will be like, whoops, my wallet's lived!
Donate $1 million!
Yes.
I require $1 million.
Oh, what's this attachment?
Wait, oh.
Yeah, no joke.
The controversy around this game looks like it was batshit.
Lole.
I think I found the news story that must have freaked Mom
out.
Video attachment.
A group of demonstrators gathered outside the Heartblade
Interactive offices this morning in protest of a
controversial new video game called Provincial Solitaire.
Did game developers burn in hell?
The game's a dark fantasy adaptation of the classic game
Solitaire recently found its way to stores and quickly drew
criticism from parent groups for its violent content the
game includes graphic scenes involving eye gouging
impalement bloody rituals and more there's no reason for it
to be this violent it's fucking solitaire the software
company responsible for the heartblade interactive has
declined to comment in the wake of the controversy the
company's founder is former fantasy author Lucas B Hart who
has recently been working to keep the game from being fanned
in several countries, including Germany, Brazil, and Brazil.
Whoa.
It has no reason to be this violent.
Wait, the key.
Okay, so we...
What's shop do?
Oh, oh, we just go back to this guy.
Okay, that's cool.
Let's play!
Find the hidden secret and clear all the cards to continue
your quest.
Whoa!
Neat!
Wild Joker, click this special card to pick it up.
This is a lock, find the key.
Click this special card to pick it up.
Oh, neat!
This would get banned in Germany so fast if real.
This might be out of turn, but if you have a contact at
YouTube, you can run...
It wasn't through YouTube.
I think Valkyrie did it a few times during a charity stream
and told people to go to the charity site.
Interesting.
That's good to know, though, for the future.
Thank you.
Unfortunately, the don't-no's were not through YouTube.
But good to know.
Good to know.
Oh.
this wild card at any time and then place a card on top of
it.
Oh, neat.
I don't think we need to right now.
Joker.
Oh, 10.
Click this card to gain some bonus mana.
In the game company...
Wait, the in-game company CEO is the same person who is the
head of the developer's company Strange Scaffold, which
helped make this game on top of Creepy Redneck Dinosaur
Mansion 3.
Man, everybody's raving about creepy redneck dinosaur
mansion 3.
I gotta hop on it.
I gotta, I'm behind on the trends.
I can't tell if it's a real game or not.
I'm gonna be honest.
Eight.
Wait.
Dang it.
Let's do, okay, we'll do this.
this.
Then we'll do the king.
Whoa.
Then we'll do the ace.
Okay, watch this.
What is this?
Manicard.
Okay.
Then we'll do the king.
Then we'll do the queen.
We got the secret!
You found the secret.
Now clear the remaining cards to continue your quest.
Yippee!
Nice.
What a nice.
But I can't do anything else.
10.
Nine.
Hmm.
Secret.
There's a three I'm still playing through the first.
Nine.
I mean, I have to clear it anyway, so neither of these will
give me a new card, unfortunately.
It'll just...
Ah!
More gold, though.
Very nice.
I can't really tell.
I guess you get less...
Oh, no.
You lose your combo, which in turn, I guess, gives you less
mana.
But...
Oh, I guess I should have done this side, huh?
Yeah.
Solitaire's awesome.
So is Minto.
Thank you!
Jolivy!
Thanks for poor bones.
I really appreciate it.
I'm kind of like trying to figure out You're out, though.
Oh, here we go.
Four.
Three.
Dang it.
Okay.
Joker.
Ah.
I wish I could do...
Oh, wait.
I could do the two, though.
There we go.
And then I could do the ace again.
And then I could do the two.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ha-ho, ha-ho, ha-ho, ha-ho.
probably becomes more important as you progress yeah yeah
probably streams time finally stopped lagging for me after
the spam oh my gosh i'm so sorry
oh my gosh stop flirting in my chat this is embarrassing
yippee victory onward and upward finally did you discover a
vital clue towards your progress you come across a
suspicious seam in a wall a hidden door perhaps spooky
solitaire with my favorite ghost mares thank you thankfully
i haven't multi-donored yet but i almost have psa for folks
who use stream labs for some reason at least for me recently
the pop-up for submitting payment doesn't go away even after
you've after you successfully paid be careful not to
multi-click that's exactly what happened to the person thank
you dorko for your For your PSA.
Now kiss.
A what wall?
A seam in the wall?
A suspicious wall?
Another small fun fact and maybe future stream for you.
Strange scaffolds.
Next game is called.
Truckland is supporting me from another world?
Sus- Sus- Ah!
Oh my god!
Suddenly the groans.
grow louder and you turn around to say a hideous sigh.
That's so mean.
He's just a guy.
The very corpse you left behind.
Oh no, that's the guy I killed.
You left behind now a shambling abomination.
Oh my gosh, we're just insulting him.
Through a miracle of the darkest forces, it still lives.
Ah!
As the groaning horror lurches toward you, you pray this
encounter will be its last.
Oh, he's gone.
Oh, just kidding.
He's gonna grab me!
No, he's gonna swipe me!
Okay.
Wait, I don't think I have enough for the- Oh, wait, what's
this?
Shuffle.
Unlock this special Joker.
Shuffle Tableau card.
Wait, this is so cool.
But I want to save up for this guy.
We just need 10 more gold.
We got this.
Fight!
to gain some temporary defense for one turn.
Oh, uh...
Hold on.
Let's do this.
Watch this.
What is this?
Click to deal instant piercing damage.
Oh dang, I can only do one or the other.
That's okay though.
Okay.
watching.
Did you check?
Did you see that?
Click this card to gain some defense.
Holy cow.
Gain some mana.
I don't know if stacking like this is good or not, but we're
just doing it anyway.
Your mana is fully charged.
Click the orb to unleash a mana storm!
Ah!
Remove at least three cards with a single Oh, mana storm!
I got an achievement.
We're watching, yeah, you're checking me out.
Still.
I don't know.
We'll go 10 Joker.
I can't, well, yeah, we'll go 10 Joker.
I wish I could go back to 9, but I can't.
And I have my 3 defense, so let's enter.
Dang, we did a ton!
and just one one move.
That was craziness.
Click to refresh.
Yeah, yeah.
Do I need to, though?
No, I don't need to.
And what?
Ah, we'll do the king.
And then back to ace.
And then there's two.
This guy's nearly dead.
Oh!
I will gain more mana.
Ah, oh, well, see ya.
Yay, caught live!
Yay!
Thanks for being here.
Anyways.
What type of belatro is this?
It's kind of...
It's actually...
I really like it so far.
The creature lies on flinching before you.
Before you.
Reduced to nothing but bones and sinew.
You redirect your attention back towards the hidden door.
There has to be a mechanism somewhere to open this.
You just need to find it.
Now he's double dead.
Oh!
What is this?
But now!
Oh my gosh, Emily!
Guessing you're busy playing the game now.
Not that you ever respond to my text timely anyway.
But lol, check this shit out.
That must be the most 90s ass ad or what?
This ad looks like those tube yogurts taste.
This ad looks like those tube yogurts.
Whoa.
You'll play so much of it, it will be in your blood.
Solitaire, like you've never seen it before.
Engage in bloody, visceral, card-based combat as you explore
a dark labyrinth.
Labyrinthian long forgotten dungeon from the creator of the
best-selling Drake Flame Chronicles book series.
Wow.
Yeah, the googer.
The googer.
Dang.
Thanks, sister.
Anyways, let's buy this.
And we can buy the shuffle.
Wait, what does it do?
Shuffle the tableau cards.
That's all I got.
Maybe we hold off.
We don't need it exactly right now.
Wait.
Because we might get another good gemmy, you know?
To unlock this sweet, play diamond sweet cards until the
counter reaches zero.
Oh, I see.
Oh, oops.
That's fine.
We'll do this one.
Yo plate so much of it.
Yo plate.
Yogurt.
I want some yogurt now.
I used to not be a Greek yogurt person, but now I'm like a
super Greek yogurt person.
Especially when you add things to it.
That's like the best.
Greek yogurt with like some berries in it.
That stuff is so delicious.
Oh, oops.
I do have to like clear this whole thing though, don't I?
LAMBO combo.
I had granola.
Yes, with granola!
Oh, yeah.
It kind of sucks because some of my favorite yogurts in
Japan are so thin and watery.
They taste really great, but like the consistency is just
kind of meh, you know what I mean?
Hello?
Give me card that I can use.
Please, thank you.
Oh, there's a thingy here.
Secret reviews.
Yippee!
Oh yeah, we're comboing.
We're comboing.
We'll go to five, to six, to five, to four, to three.
Oh yeah!
Wicked combo.
Whoa!
Make a combo of 10 or higher!
I got a wicked!
WW, wicked witch.
Flip it around.
Wait.
No.
M.M.
Made mint.
Flip it around.
Wicked Wint.
The texture is important.
Have you ever tried Wii yogurt?
No, I never.
Wicked Wint.
Hmm.
This is not ideal though.
This is kind of stinky actually.
Oh, eight.
Thank goodness.
Okay.
There we go.
Yay!
So my favorite part is the stylish way you say flip it
around.
MF, mint phantom, flip it around.
Freaking mint!
I like flailed my arms back.
in excitement and hit something.
Alas, you find it.
Beneath the dust and rubble of a dark, cobwebbed corner, a
switch.
Oh, yeah.
Just before they go up in price.
You depress it, and with a loud roar, you hear the hidden
doorway open.
We gotta get you some hand-tracking.
I can't be contained.
As the stone door slowly grinds open before you, rocky
debris begins to spill outward.
As the door opens fully, it reveals its horror.
Oh god, it's people!
A foul, salt-like stench fills the air.
Ew.
Your eyes behold the passageway.
Filled to the brim with the calcified remains of countless
corpses.
To discover what's at the end of this chamber, you fear
you'll have to disturb there.
Why is it salty, though?
Oh, so these are...
This is Spade, right?
We have new things at the shop?
Ooh, stormy cores.
Boost power of mana cards.
Quasi-crystal.
Combo start after a run of five cards instead of six.
Oh!
Okay.
We could get both, right?
This one's 80.
Three.
Four.
No!
Almost.
Can we cast Fireball?
Can we cast...
Doom?
Shuffle seems strong.
I agree.
What if we...
get shuffle and also quasi-crystal?
Doom.
Or, I don't know, maybe mana would be... The mana storm was
really good.
So maybe the mana cards instead.
Let's get- for- for now, let's get the shuffle.
Can this game run, too?
I'm gonna get this- We'll get the stormy one.
For the mana cards.
Lucky.
Whoa!
Sick.
Okay, here we go.
We're playing?
This old magazine...
Shit, her messages take me out.
Found this old magazine review of the game.
Apparently, it was so buggy, they couldn't even finish it.
So, beware of bugs, I guess.
4 out of 10!
Not Romero!
Like...
Doom?
The gameplay is also deceptively simple, but opens up its
strategic depth over the course of its game run run time
ray romano
ray romero the abilities are fun to use but occasionally bug
out causing me to lose battles i was otherwise winning uh oh
wait is that gonna happen to me and the graphics while
amazing at times are disrupted regularly by groups of pixels
appearing to come from some late game enemy that didn't seem
like it was meant to appear yet oh that happened to us
earlier Nothing like some Minto to go with the gas station
glizzies after a long day.
Big Minto sip.
Thank you.
Be careful of them glizzies though.
As the game was fighting itself at every turn whenever it
show up.
In conclusion, while Heartblade Interactive may have
captured the attention of Pearl clutching parents
everywhere, with its dark, gory take on Solitaire, it's just
too glitchy to recommend to even the edgiest teen.
One particularly devastating bug even prevented me from
being able to see the game's conclusion.
Perhaps Forbidden Solitaire should have stayed forbidden
from store shelves after all.
Reviewer can't get past the beginning.
Too many numbers.
Four out of ten.
I know how these reviewers work.
It was sideways.
No ace.
Oh.
Noise.
Find a key.
Oh,
nice.
Yay!
Three.
Two.
I'm gonna do this four instead of this two.
Aha!
We'll open up this one.
Two.
10 out of 10.
Too much dungeon.
And before Emily finds that reviewer died.
No!
Too spooky!
Too scary.
That doesn't really help us so much.
Oh, I should have gone for the Joker instead!
I was a fool.
That was a fool.
We'll do it here.
I don't know.
Oops.
Shuffle!
Wait, I want to see it work.
Whoa!
Secret Reveal.
Uh, uh.
I wish I could do the same.
Now we just got it individually.
You got the magic torch.
I do.
Oh, I could have done that one, too.
It's okay, though.
Your mana blast.
Yeah, I'm waiting.
I was saving it for...
I think it, like, builds up.
Like, I think next enemy, I'll also be able to use it.
Pretty sure.
Salty dust.
Why are they salty?
Powders your lungs as you finally move past the last bit of
bony debris out of your way.
at last through the hidden passage.
You gather your strength and step forward into the darkness.
You don't want to know.
I kind of want to know.
Kind of curious.
Salt life!
No!
As you march your way through the shadowed halls, you hear
your footsteps echo.
You stop in place, but the footsteps continue.
Just as you feared, you're being followed.
This is the Salt Life Chamber.
It is!
Turning around, you witness a grotesque horror limping its
way towards you!
The figure illuminates as it drags itself into your faint
light.
You recognize its horrible mangled visage.
It's still alive!
How could it still be living?
Oh my gosh, this guy.
Permanent defense.
This enemy will always block some of your basic damage.
No!
That's fine.
Buy it.
Ew!
My hand grows hairier.
I'm collecting the infinity stones for real.
He's such a good tutorial boss.
He came back three times.
I love it.
I love to see it happen.
He's gonna swipe me again.
How much damage?
Three damage!
Noix.
Alright, let's try this.
Let's give us a defense and another defense.
And then I'm gonna mana.
I'm gonna mana storm.
And another defense.
Do I want a five or do I want the seven?
Hold on.
If I do the five, I don't think either will give me...
This one will give me the instant.
This one.
There, we're piercing damage.
I guess I made up my mind.
Yeah, if only I had a six.
Yeah, it's okay, though.
Don't say it, you guys.
Don't say it.
What's this?
What times two?
Whoa, nice.
And another!
He can't.
go with the 10.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go with the 10.
Then I'm gonna shuffle.
Shuffle, baby.
Shuffle!
Roku 9-ar.
More mana.
And burn.
Three.
Two.
Ouch.
Nothing else.
Ew!
Oh, this is kind of stinky, huh?
No!
Oh, yikes.
He's gonna swipe, mate.
Might be worth refreshing.
Oh, like that.
Oh, I didn't realize it did the whole board.
You know what, that's okay.
Honestly, we almost got him.
We'll grab some more defense.
We'll grab some more mana.
I can't quite tell if I'm doing like the strategy of this
game like as it should be so much such a moist attack sound
right let me know we can loot him you unlock this special
joker removed remove a targeted playable card nice I think
okay now he has literal nothingness
Relentless, you continue your assault on the poor soul until
it has broken into hundreds of bony shattered pieces across
the dark hall.
It's fucking solitaire.
As you begin to make your way back into the dungeon, you
hear a rattling sound as the shattered remains begin to
shiver and the blood begins to rise.
Oh, a pooling red whirlwind forms in front of you.
a hundred of disparate bones, meat, and gristle from
throughout the dark halls begin to assemble.
I'm saying you're lowless.
Who's gonna come back from the puddle?
Why'd you manifest that?
You run down the hall as fast as your feet can carry you,
and unholy shriek echoes throughout the chamber.
Your heart leaps with joy as you witness a familiar sight
approach.
A door!
The shriek grows loud With swiftness, you attempt to pull it
open, only for it to pull back against you.
The door is locked!
You turn around and witness a horrific sight!
A hulking, malformed effigy of bones and tissue, rampaging
towards you!
I'm in the defense, too?
He's gonna...
A hideous curse that afflicts cards and reduces your health
by five.
I don't think there's anything new at the shop.
Okay.
A lot of bones, yeah.
Okay!
Alright, we're gonna take you.
We're gonna deal you.
And we're gonna deal you.
And we're gonna unlock you.
We're gonna deal you.
Okay, two.
Ace.
What we could do is...
Deal this.
And then it would be 8-9-8.
Yeah, 8-9-8.
Nothing.
And I end my turn.
Now we're in the bone zone!
Curse cards need to be played twice to remove them.
This guy's cheating.
I don't know what to play.
Maybe the king.
That didn't do much.
King?
No, you can't do Joker.
You gotta have the queen.
2-3-2!
Ah!
You guys are so right!
Oh, I made the mistake.
I made a mistake.
Mistaki.
Oh, but this, here we go.
Here we go, here we go.
The two.
Nice, okay.
Alright.
It ended up working out.
More defense.
Uh...
Nothing.
Eight.
Nine.
Oh, finally, a queen!
My queen!
Filker?
Queen!
Remove a target.
What does that mean?
Mystic Missile.
Which one?
Okay.
I could also do the Joker again.
Queen bottom right?
You have an undo button!
Is this my undo button right here?
Yes.
Yes, that's right.
I do.
Thank you for reminding me.
Maybe like a targeted mana burst.
Like if I used it.
If I say I'd use this king.
Then I could blast this Joker.
Jack.
Maybe it'll reveal all of these.
I think that's how that works, so let's try it.
Wait!
Oh, well, actually I could just grab it anyway.
I don't need to do that.
Combo!
Yeah!
Um...
I think it might be worth shuffling the cards this time.
Oh yeah.
Big damage!
You know what?
Well, not.
Oh yeah, okay, that is how it works.
You know what?
Let's continue the combo.
Oh, I wish I had put it there.
And...
We'll do that.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Six, seven.
No!
Boo!
Bad joke!
Oh, dang it.
I wish I had gone back to the 7 so I could do the 8 and the
9.
Roku nirna.
I'm still on Hakutua.
Aww.
I wish...
I wish I were still there.
Let's see.
I don't want to waste my wild card.
Shuffle!
Let's shuffle these.
Oh, I should...
Does it...
Waste it?
I wonder.
Ah!
I don't want to waste my Joker on these, you know what I
mean?
Oh, it does waste it.
Oh, that's so stinky.
That is so stinky.
I think I have to now, though.
Okay.
But it does not do much for me at the moment.
Ouch!
No!
Wait, here we go.
Wombo-combo.
This will be good damage.
He hits me with, like, five.
sucks oh gosh oh it's so bad i wish i could get my mana up
this is tricky the two armor is blocking so much of our
damages i know right this one's tough this one's tricky i
feel like i used all my stuff too so i'm like kind of and i
can't reshuffle again so i have to get through this oh my
gosh I feel like we're done, though.
My mana is so close.
Oh, jeez.
We're, like, in bad dire strait.
Yeah, we might be cooked.
We might be cooked.
Uh-oh.
No, we're not cooked!
That was so close!
That was so close.
Holy cow.
There must be a way to stop this terror for good.
As the creature stands dazed, weakened by your assault, you
plunge your hand into its swirling bloody core.
Suddenly you feel a pulse.
You grip and tear!
From the beast.
You inspect your hand to find a bloody beating heart.
What unholy magic drives its rhythm.
Hiroshi clutched.
Clutch, baby!
Clutch!
The creature stirs.
You better start your investigation with haste.
Okay, investigate the heart.
Oh, holy sheesh.
I found a police report that was filed with the studio just
before the game came out.
Why wasn't this the controversy?
How did they keep this quiet?
TLDR, a developer died by suicide in the studio.
Here's the report I found.
Be warned.
It's a graphic.
Okay, we've been warned, everybody.
Shots frozen.
Oh, thank you.
What?
This is a suicide.
Name Shannon.
This does not look self-inflicted.
Location Heartblade Interactive.
Summary is Sunday, March 5th, 1995.
A break-in was reported at, what is that?
10.21 p.m.
When Blank arrived at the scene, victim was found.
dead in the office a blank lying near a compact disc victim
found with two identical daggers plunged into eye sockets
room was locked and security oh my gosh locked room case oh
my gosh someone conan detective conan conan edogawa is on
the case security cameras confirmed wounds were
self-inflicted no additional evidence found cool daggers
though look at this sick edit well we got new step of the
What's this?
Gem of Scrying.
Turns over 20% of face down cards at the start of each hand.
I'll buy that.
Conan Edogawa, the Grim Reaper everywhere he goes, someone
dies.
Phoenix Wright walks in and promptly walks out.
This is maybe a little too much for my little guy.
Okay.
Let's get some mana.
Nice.
Um...
Yippee!
No fours, no toes.
Nine.
I don't think I can get that eight, no.
Ten.
Uh...
Let's do this and then this.
Instead.
I still gotta get rid of this guy too, though.
Uh, we are We are exploring this with much haste.
We are being so hasty.
We are taking no time.
We are rushing completely.
Gonna hit the hay.
Good night!
Good night.
Thanks for hanging out.
Queen.
My queen.
I have no use for you at the moment.
Oh, shoot.
I should have gotten on this one.
Oopsie.
Oh, well.
6...
5.
And then 6.
And then...
The number above it.
I wish I could get this 8.
6 5.
The hit meme.
Oops, you missed a card.
I did?
Oh, I did!
Oh my gosh!
The game is backseeding me.
6 number above it
I'm not doing so great at this one you guys That's fine Why
did this shake?
Wait did I miss it?
Oh, my bad
Oh, I should have used that one Oh my gosh, I'm really
Yeah, you had a 7 Ah!
It's fine.
I'm not locked in at all.
I gotta lock in.
Yippee!
Okay, we finally broke that one!
Oh!
Finally!
Okay, come on.
Please, I wish I could get this eight.
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
You die when your hand ends.
No way.
Oh, okay, we're fine.
I died!
It's fine.
I was just curious what happens if you die.
Now I know.
It's so uninteresting, you guys.
You don't want to die.
It's like so uninteresting if you die.
It's like, you know, you don't even want to try it.
Because it's just so boring.
Boring if you do.
Whamble, combo.
Wait, do I have anything?
I have this other ten, but...
No nine, no.
Two, three, four, five, six.
The number above it, back to six, and the number above it.
Look now, look, I'm killing it now, you guys.
Look at this, isn't this crazy?
You're so impressed now?
You're so impressed?
That number, you mean six sharp or eight flat?
Wicked combo.
Thank you!
We'll save, we'll save this for battle.
18.
Ace.
Three.
Eight, nine.
I did it?
Oh, ten!
Ah!
That's fine.
We can use it.
Thank you.
And take that.
And you know what?
We'll just do that and that.
Now we just need...
You!
Oh, I guess I could have used this too, huh?
Oh well.
Yay!
Do you think something as silly as death will let you leave
Q game title forbidden solitaire?
Oh, yes, that's so true!
We didn't go back to the...
The title screen, did we?
Complete the spade dungeon.
After a thorough and bloody excavation, you find it, nestled
inside one of its veins a key you extract it pulls a blood
splash to the floor and the bony debris clatters around you
the heart stops beating the beast is no more you have
defeated Shia LeBuff you're pretty wicked you turn and
approach the door the key fits into the lock perfectly whoa
as the door swings open your vision blurs red with the sight
of blood-coated jail cells as far as the eye could see
distant cries of agony fill the iron scented air actual
cannibal I mean a guy did try to eat me so me though the
solitaire master I love numbers I love numbers I don't love
numbers cautiously you step forward into the hall you hear
the sounds of chains dragging near as you turn toward the
sound with a loud thwack your head suddenly throbbs with
pain you fall to the floor your vision turns black darkness
blackness in the unconscious void your mind begins to wander
and conjure a friendly face perhaps die oh my game froze
joke oh oh oh can i shop
yeah this is a friendly face i guess i'm feeling i'm feeling
befriended Truly.
I'm gonna mana scum!
What does he do?
It looks like a Joker, so maybe he changes this card?
Perhaps?
Maybe?
And I end my turn.
What does this do?
Huh?
Your birthday merch finally came in the mail, and the
Mintapuma was very throwing.
I feel like if you throw her, she will definitely knock
something over and break her.
Maybe even break the wall.
So, please be careful.
Great, Kurita.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Try it.
Yippee!
Okay, cool.
I'll take it.
Let's get rid of...
No, let's save it.
And now I end my...
I wish I could take this one too.
I can't tell.
Well, yeah, my health is definitely going down.
Ah, this is so stinky.
Getting such stinky pulls.
Nothing bad happens if you click...
Yeah, nothing bad ever happens if you click random things or
press random buttons or anything.
Use the Joker.
Get rid of the A.
Yeah.
I think it's a good point too.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
There we go.
Cosmic beyond comprehension change cards to the same number.
Wait a second.
We're going to do this.
And then we're going to do this.
And then I'm going to use it.
Oh, I should have.
Wait, that's fine.
Oh, they all changed the kings!
Shovel!
That worked in my favor.
Very nice.
And I end my turn.
Oh, shoot.
I thought I was on the 8.
Ah!
I feel like I should refresh.
I don't remember what this is.
You know?
This guy is cool, but I'm dying.
I'm like dying like crazy.
Was it a king?
Refresh.
Yeah, let's do it.
Five.
Let's grab this.
Let's grab that.
I guess I feel like I should save these, but at the same
time, also...
I also feel like I need to use them.
Because I need to get more cards.
You know what I mean?
Now, which... What do we do here?
Holy cow.
We can do... We have so many moves.
We can do... All these aides, or we can do three tens.
Save them for Forbidden Solitaire 2.
You're so right!
Oh, it damaged me!
Oh my gosh, you're right!
So it's evil, evil.
It did damage to me and him.
Ouch!
Ouchie, ouch.
Left 10 opens a new card.
This one.
Oh, that's right.
Out of all of these, only this one would open a new cart,
huh?
A ten.
Oh, great.
Oh, wait.
A queen.
Yeah.
Shuffle!
Magic missile!
Dang.
That didn't do it what I wanted it to do, but that's okay.
Oh, he's gonna swipe- Guys, we're dead!
Six damage on me.
We're dead.
This is it.
Oh, wait.
I do three damage.
Ah!
Woo!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that was so close.
That was close.
You pry open your weary eyes to find yourself in a cramped,
rusty jail cell.
The pungent odor of blood and iron assaults your senses as
you begin to gather your surroundings.
Naked man!
It seems you aren't alone as you catch sight of another poor
soul trapped in this cell with you.
Perhaps together you may find a way to escape.
As you approach your cellmate, you realize they aren't
breathing.
This cell was their tomb.
It may yet be yours.
What's wrong with your face?
You push those thoughts aside and focus on searching the
body for anything useful.
oh my my skill reveals some in the back oh we can get some
new stuff what's this transmutation trade mana for five
health cost 10 mana mana whichever gemini stone doubles mana
generation a combo 10 and above am i ever gonna get that
this one would be good for like a honestly why don't we just
get both i have the money for it mana i'll make manna out of
you oh okay man i don't even have any moves okay so it gets
weirder if you believe it remember that true crime mystery
show truth or tale factor fiction beyond belief i watched it
all the time i always wanted to be on that show i was like
oh my gosh what if somebody sees me and then does a factor
fiction about me and they're like i went to this cafe but it
wasn't a real cafe and it was actually an abandoned cafe but
it was haunted but it looked like a real I left, I turned
around and I was at Abandoned Cafe.
Ah!
With Jonathan!
Jonathan Franks, yes!
I love that show.
Guess they did an episode on this game, but it was taken off
the air after complaints.
So, yeah, I had to see it.
This is the only partial recording of the episode I can
find.
Prepare yourself.
It's kind of effed.
I really use back-to-back-to-back-to-back.
Wait, this is so awesome!
We made it up.
I love that show.
But tonight, we ask a different type of question.
Can video games kill?
Tonight we'll answer that question as we dive into the
mystery.
I had that whole show on DVD.
Oh, this is so awesome!
I love this show.
Banned video game.
Or is it just a tale?
tale!
This is awesome.
Truth or tale!
Oh my god, my show is on?
Everybody, please, please.
Don't bother me, kid.
And video games, cute.
Even the purple background.
I know!
Timmy Garriott was always a well-behaved- And the cadence of
his speaking also.
He had his eyes set on becoming an astronaut when he grew
up.
changed by soaps I didn't even know he had a coffee found it
no where's my where's my recreation of the story after
it was responsible for what happened to him
but the circumstances around his death were nothing short of
extraordinary no the way he's speaking is almost like the
evidence of any guy who narrates Twilight Zone.
There's no obvious leads to follow.
I must warn you.
Timmy!
If you're about to watch, some of you may find.
Oh my god!
Timmy!
Why would they air that on TV?
No wonder it got pulled.
Wait, I think I missed one of the little blips.
Why would they air that on TV?
Yeah, I'm Rob Sterling.
Serling.
Oh yeah.
Timmy!
Anyway, I'm gonna keep playing this game.
It killed people?
Whoa.
Anyway.
Oh, I have the king.
Which king should I use, though?
Let's do this one.
And we'll go back to the ace, and we'll do the king again.
That should be all I can do at the moment.
This is like Jumanji.
It is, almost, right?
Timmy should have stuck to watching VTubers.
If I play the game and I'm a ghost, then you have nothing to
worry about.
I don't think it's like the ring.
That'd be kind of messed up, though.
If you watch the game, you also die.
Oof.
The music is good, though.
Um, I could also do this Joker.
I mean, I always call it a Joker, Jack.
Yeah, I'm gonna scoot over a tiny tad.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Jack, then Queen?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
You guys are so smart.
I love having you around.
Then we'll do this.
Oh, shoot.
For some reason I thought it would give me three and four.
That's okay though.
Seven.
Eight.
No!
Got your back, boss.
Thank you.
Well, that's no good.
Let's do the...
Let's do this, King.
We have to get it eventually, you know, so...
Sorry, I'm so snotty.
I'm sorry.
2-3-4!
You're right!
Thank you, guys.
You're noticing all these things that I'm not...
I need to lock in.
Effect of the game.
Yeah, I have too much ectoplasm!
Can't use...
Which six do we unlock?
This one!
Yeah, baby!
If only I had another seven.
Oh!
Six!
We're running out of cards.
Eight.
to 9, to 10.
Yavi!
Victory!
That jonkler sure is a spooky one.
Make sure to play your cards, right?
Thank you, Silver!
After much searching, you come across something in your
cellmate's pocket.
A key.
How strange that prisoner would die holding the answer to
their own salvation.
It must have another purpose.
Suddenly, a frigid head Who could have imagined?
Reaches out and clutches your shoulder.
A mad gurgling shriek pierces the air.
Ew, the hands in his mouth.
The hands in his everywhere.
Help me!
The prisoner cries desperately through a choking wet cough.
Before you can spare a thought.
The prisoner's chest bursts outwards and hundreds of
writhing maggots swarm their way toward you.
Eww!
Oh, we're fighting the maggots.
A disgusting spew of maggots that infest cards?
Nasty.
Take that.
And take that.
Eight.
Seven.
Dude, the infested cards attack me.
We'll do damage, or we'll do that just in case.
Oh, good.
That gives us a nine.
Too bad we don't have a 10.
2.
Actually,
my skin is crawling.
It's icky.
Wait, this game is so fun, though, Desko.
You should play it, too.
Why did the maggots look like croissants?
They make me hungry.
Yeah, it does kind of look like a croissant.
Kind of make me hungry.
Let's mana storm so that we can build up mana again.
I think it's good to, like, you know...
It didn't really help so much.
I was hoping it would get rid of this fool.
Dang it.
That's okay.
When played, the card explodes.
It inflicting one damage.
No!
Deflect a maggot or a crystal card.
I deflected it.
Oh, wait.
Oh, shoot.
It's five.
Okay, we deflected that, too.
We're so good.
We're so good at this.
game um i'm at five six no fours no sevens card squeezy wait
i could do this ace and then we could get the two as well
let's draw it oh one more combo baby oh Oh, it was such a
good move.
It was such a good move.
And I end my turn.
Oh!
That didn't make a damage.
I think we're going to be good then.
If I do one damage.
YouTube superstar, Mint Phantom.
Living in your closet.
Mint Phantom.
Obsconding with all your panties.
What is, what is this Spectre?
Um, we'll kill him.
CD, Mega Damage.
You pray that you banish the last of those putrid maggots,
but it's still...
Oh, I thought this was a hole.
It still feels as though they're crawling all over your
skin.
Ew.
You take a moment to compose yourself before making your way
to the rusty cell gate.
You try the key you found in the gate's lock.
No avail.
It appears you shall have to force this open the skit the
hard way.
Through cards!
You force the door open.
Oh.
Dude, I searched for police reports from 1995 that match the
description of Timmy's and yeah, not only is this legit,
there's more of these?
Same manner of death.
No suspects, no evidence.
Real creepy pasta.
Sheesh.
His eyes her ears splouted.
Oh my god.
Scary.
Emily!
You're scaring me!
That's literally gonna be us.
We're so screwed.
Wardstone.
Boost power of defense cards.
Oh yeah, that's great.
And what's this do?
Special Joker.
Remove targeted playable card and up to two random cards.
nearby let's grab them both or can i do both yeah oh my gosh
i'm so blinged out you guys
okay wow you give me nothing to start with this is awesome
oh so kind of you game again oh i was scared for I was like,
wait a second.
Is the game, like, forcing me to die?
Hope those gems don't get infected.
I know, right?
Made-Mit Thanos.
Oh, dang it.
If only I had the three, I could go back.
They're giving me...
Oh, shoot.
Ah, dang it!
Okay, I'll just undo.
I'll undo, I'll undo.
I always forget the ace and the king and stuff, you know?
That one's so easy to miss for me.
No!
Oh, this is fine.
Maybe.
I will use it on this.
Oh, well.
I guess you can't win them all.
This is not so good, you guys.
Mom, input our hand in the gems and jam again.
Oh, the gems and the gems.
This is bad.
This is bad, bad.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my
gosh.
Please!
Ugh!
I'm gonna run out of cards again.
I'm gonna run out.
Toil!
The uncut gems?
No!
We die.
It's Jover.
That's gonna have- that's gonna be me!
That's gonna be me!
It's literally going to show my webcam and be like...
Actually, you're going to see my eyes just...
Have you noticed that we don't go back to the main menu?
Can we quit the game, I wonder?
I do wonder...
Oh my gosh, it gave us such a butt...
We have moves!
We already have a better hand.
Try?
I will after this.
Oh, I guess I could have done that one too.
That's okay though.
Trapped in the video game.
We're stuck?
Nah.
I'd win.
I don't know.
Why would you ever want to quit?
Why?
Why would you want to quit?
Why am I a vampire?
Why?
At least we have this in case we need it.
Whamble combo!
Whamble combo.
And the combo.
It's a Whamble combo.
Okay, we have like two numbers that we need.
Okay, good.
Yahoo!
Okay.
Don't say it?
Okay, I'm not gonna say it.
have oh thank goodness I
guess I could have done that as like a last resort so I
could save it but it's whatever I totally forgot to mention
but strange scaffold also made El Paso elsewhere which was
heavily inspired by Max Payne Alan Wake wait what oh wait
that sounds legit that sounds real are these real finally
the lock gives away and the cell gate jars open cautiously
you open the gate and step into the long hallway where
countless cells stretch into the darkness you pick a
direction and begin to journey down the corridor this is
exactly what we did before you ignore the pleading cries
coming from various cells as you make your way through the
seemingly endless hall whoa all at once the prisoners cries
fall silent you hear the sound of chains dragging the floor
rumbles rhythmically something is coming this way something
big you need to hide okay
beware removing cards in the enemies gauge will alert them
for a short time sneak past the guard what the hell is this
oh my god i'm playing metal gear oh no i shouldn't have done
that uh if If I do this though, well, if it unlocks in here,
let's test.
Okay.
That was fine.
Spooky!
Oh my gosh!
Cool!
And scary at the same time.
This is freaky.
Does this count?
Let's try.
Oh, okay.
If they're outlined, it counts.
It counts.
Got it.
Oh, I can't get this because of the five.
That's stinky.
Sneak past the guard.
I could do...
Okay, we could do eight and seven.
Nice.
We could do the five.
Four.
Uh...
I guess that doesn't really matter.
Three?
Two?
Big combo.
Nice.
Her deck is dummy thick and the shuffling of her cards are
alluring the guards.
Wait, then we can do it!
Oh, I can't do this three anyway.
Never mind.
Okay.
That's the only one I could do.
Oh, this is gonna get tough when...
I couldn't!
Wait, could I have done it?
If I undo...
Ah!
Oh, it didn't...
Oh, geez.
I wasted it.
Did you think I was lying about all the game titles I've
mentioned so far?
Everything from Creepy Redneck Dinosaur Mansion 3 to El
Paso.
It can be found on...
What?
Yeah, the vision doesn't undo.
I messed up.
Ah!
And it taunted me again.
Don't say it.
Oh.
Oh, dang it, I was thinking.
Yes, I can do it.
Okay.
I looked it up.
He ain't lying.
You're pulling my leg.
No!
What happens if we alert him?
This is for science, everybody.
Oh, wee.
Oh my gosh, no!
Wait, we could do this.
Should I...
Yeah, I think I should.
Yahoo!
Mana storm, we don't have it yet.
It's got to build up more.
Quietly, you creep into a nearby empty cell undetected as
the stomping abomination drives me.
near you catch a glimpse of it as it moves past you chains
drag as it trudges through the hallway barely big enough to
contain it your lungs strain under the pressure you don't
dare exhale exhale until the echoed clobber of its titanic
gate fades the ground settles beneath your feet as it strays
further down the hall you can finally breathe again in your
relief you lean against the wall and feel a loose brick
depressed again against your back.
With a stony click, you can now hear the grinding sounds of
a secret passageway revealed behind you.
Turning around, you see a small tunnel opening in the wall
near the floor, just big enough to crawl through.
As you inch your way through the narrow passage, you feel
the dirt beneath you shake with stomping once again.
Growing louder!
Wait, are these maggots too?
Or are they croissants?
You crawl your way deeper into the tunnel as the booming
draws close Closer!
Your body jolts to a halt!
A hollow roar fills the masier!
You feel the coil of a gargantuan grip seizing your leg!
Dungeon chrissants?
Yeah, they're definitely chrissants.
Oh no, wait.
Restrain, suit locks fasten upon cards, causing one damage.
Oh, he's got a defense on him!
Bolts down.
Manistorm to remove four random playable cards.
We only have enough for it.
Doubles Manistorm damage.
Single use.
Wait, which ones would be better, though?
This one gets four random playable cards.
Wait.
How many does it do right now?
Get the big one?
Oh, yeah.
This one is single use.
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
Yeah, you're so right.
Ew!
Oh, no!
Oh, my pinky!
Ouch!
Alright, let's fight.
Let's grab more.
And more?
Nice.
I don't know if I need the...
Let's just grab it.
Nice.
Because he's gonna do something to inflict damage, right?
Oh, we deflected.
We did deflect.
Ugh.
Oh, I should have done this three instead.
I think I messed up.
No!
I don't want to undo, though.
I don't want to undo.
Yeah, he's got a ton of life.
Yeah, he's gonna be really beefy.
This is gonna be tough.
I'm gonna have to really lock in the numbers the numbers
actually that's fine he's gonna okay we'll get at least two
health there okay that was good that was good and you know
what I'll just shuffle anyway shuffle it did not help Help
me out.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, this is hard.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh.
Oh my God, he's, I'm not doing any damage to this guy.
Oh, this sucks.
I need the mana storm like right now.
Queen.
King.
Dang it, why couldn't you be another queen?
Yeah, the walk was hurting me.
We should do one damage now, yeah.
My mana storm!
That did help.
I ended my turn.
Okay, combo.
Good combo, good damage.
Can we at least get a damage in?
Okay.
I think I'm gonna refresh.
Yeah, that's kind of all I really can do.
You know he's gonna do damage to me.
Shuffle card.
You...
No!
Wee!
Shuffle!
Maybe we'll get the...
Oh.
No, that's mana.
I was hoping we would get the defense.
But actually, this kind of helps.
Yes!
Okay, good.
We got at least a little defense.
Yeah, we can heal, but we have to get to 10.
It costs 10 mana.
Oh, good!
We got even more!
Okay, good.
He'll only do one damage to us now.
Okay, good, good, good.
Let's do...
I'm like, do I want to do it on the floor so that I can get
the Insta inflict?
Or I could do it on something like the 10 and get two more.
Oh the 7-8 is playable!
Oh my god, I thought you guys were just saying that.
I thought you guys were just...
Then I will shoot the 4.
We're gonna do, like, mega damage right now.
And it goes back to seven!
Yeah, baby!
Oh my gosh, super damage.
And we only take one damage in return.
Yes.
Nice.
Oh, I'm glad I didn't hit that 10.
Oh, but it doesn't give us anything.
That kind of sucks.
We're not making a new trend.
Honest.
Ouch!
Oh no.
No, no.
Ugh.
Okay, he's resting, so I'm not gonna heal just yet.
We needed that three.
We did!
So stinky.
Let's do this.
Two.
Actually, is kind of good.
So then we could go ace and then two again.
do I do the ace or do I do the three?
I think we got him though.
Don't we?
Oh, yeah, baby!
We're so in the clear.
We got him.
I'm just gonna, you know, I'll take it anyway and we end up.
Loot.
You unlocked a special Joker.
the suit of all playable cards to match the target also
cleanses some mal mal mal mal mal maline maline effects but
the bloodiest spurt in a shrieking howl the beast's arm rips
free of its owner malign malign malign the tunnel quakes as
the creature stomps away in agony well we'll be seeing him
again for sure Shaking free of its severed grip, you focus
your attention on the dark, twisting tunnel that lies ahead.
Surprised Emily hasn't a...
Little maggots!
Surprise she hasn't messaged us yet.
Hey, thank you for meeting with us at Heartblade today.
What is this?
Hold on, I know this.
Hold on.
What's happening?
Shannon, did I get it?
Uh, yeah.
um indeed that's right and thank you for the opportunity mr
heart huh just call me lucas anyway to start things off why
do you want to work here at heart blade of all places
shannon well i guess i've been a long time fan of the drake
flame chronicle series for one thing oops is shannon the one
that died blatant tactical flattery side let's take a look
at your resume here so it looks like this would be your
first real gig fresh computer science graduate and all do
you think you're up for the challenge Shannon Shannon the
kind of games we're making here they're not for the faint
hearted you know oh most definitely this is really kind of
the dream job making games I used to make little ASCII
dungeon crawlers between my courses actually one of them
even got passed around campus for a while it's fucking
solitaire what was that called Warlocks Tower 3 Warlocks
Tower 3 I kind of had a whole series going by that point
it's really the whole reason I got into programming being
able to create games for other people to enjoy feels feels
kind of like magic you know yes yes magic that's the perfect
word for it i'm gonna well that's exactly what we're setting
out to do here what are we doing we're trying to create
magic
Okay, trying to create magic.
Wait, magic the gathering?
And it's a card game?
When did magic the gathering come out?
Is this plagiarism?
Yippee!
Yuchi!
Oh, dang.
Oh, I thought I ended on the ace.
Oh, boo.
This one changes the suit of all playable cards to match the
target card.
Does the suit count though?
Do we get more mana if we play the same...
No, we shouldn't.
I don't know, actually.
I have no idea.
1993 for Magic the Gathering.
Didn't it say this came out in 97?
Oh, it mattered for the locks.
Oh, that's right.
You're so right.
It did matter for the locks.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Uh, hello.
Please give me something that I can use.
Oh, shoot.
Well, I would have then been stuck with three kings, so
honestly it's okay.
Oh my god, please.
No, please, give me something I can use!
Okay.
Oh, this is not good.
That jungler will clear effects too?
Oh yeah, we'll clear this guy.
Okay.
We might need to use this.
Oh no, that's such a waste.
Let's get to the end and see.
We might get something.
I...
Oh no!
I had to redo it.
Oh, that's okay.
We're dead.
We're died.
Our eyes are gonna pop out for real.
Am I gonna have to listen to the interview again?
How exciting.
Five.
Really?
Nothing!
This game is so rude.
Ouch!
Let's do this one instead so we can get a new card.
We do eventually have to do this one though.
Actually, we'll do it right now.
That should be everything.
No jack and no king.
Here come the voices again.
I'm not hearing them.
Wait, ah!
I'm gonna redo that, sorry.
Okay.
Like, give us a few more.
You don't hear them.
Rout roll.
Shit!
No, I took my medicine!
I swear!
I swear it.
I took my medicine!
I swear!
Hmm.
Let's do five.
Nasty.
Ugh.
We'll take that.
Three.
Eight.
Six.
This game is so fascinating.
Nisu.
Not Nisu right now.
Ouch!
Destroy 10 maggots.
Wait, it was already charged!
No!
I messed up.
Nice.
Do you think we'll make it?
I think we'll make it.
I don't know.
You'll be okay.
Seems iffy.
I think we might have to use the mana.
What a waste.
Wait, because we died, we'll retry.
Wait, hold on.
Let's do the thing where we close out of the game.
Do you really want to exit?
Your progress on this hand will be lost.
Level 60, like, that's what we want to do, right?
Anything freaky on our computer?
Messages?
Wait.
Oh, it shows us, like, the old messages, too.
Stats?
Wow.
This shows us everything too, all of our stats.
Wait, don't throw Fluminto into the wall.
Oops, hashtag Minto to go.
What did you...
Seymour, what did you do?
I thought maybe our wallpaper would be kind of freaky or
something, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, continue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, okay.
All right, we're back at it.
Oh no, now we have to listen to it again because I quit out.
No!
Shannon, did I get it?
Yeah.
My bad.
Indeed, that's right.
And thank you for the opportunity, Mr. Hart.
Huh, just call me Lucas.
Anyway, start things off.
Why do you want to work here at Heartblade of all places?
Well, Lucas.
Well, Lucas?
Well, oh Lucas?
You sly rascal.
Let's take a look at your resume.
That was a great combo.
Yeah, wicked.
Oh shoot, I should have done this one.
Oh well.
Do you think you're up for the challenge, Shannon?
The kind of games we're making here, not for the fans.
heart oh most definitely this is really kind of the dream
job oh yeah there we go okay good i used to make little asky
dungeon crawlers between my courses actually one of them
even got passed around the campus for a while oh really okay
warlocks tower three i i i kind of had a whole series going
by that point um Really the whole reason I got into
programming.
So far so good.
Voices, what voices?
You took your meds.
I'm so jealous.
Osos!
I lost my job a bit over a month ago.
But I was lucky enough to find a new one that pays almost
double.
Yippee!
Congrats!
Congratulations, Osos!
I'm glad that it didn't last too long.
Just think of it as an extended vacation that you had.
Extended vacation, bye-bye.
Oh, shoot, I was supposed to...
Whatever.
Does anyone else feel like this interview belongs in those
anti-harassment videos?
Shannon.
I think you...
Yeah, I think you might be right.
Oh, good, good.
Ouch.
We're so close, you guys.
Wait, this is good!
This is good!
Clean, clean, clean!
That was so clean!
That was so good!
You just need the right hand, the right shuffle.
A real life horror of this game.
My job!
I mean, we know Shannon got the job.
Your knees and hands ache as you scrabble your way through
the tunnels many twists and turns.
A foul, pungent odor overwhelms the senses.
You need to get out of here.
At last, your spirits lift as you spot a grate ahead.
You pray it leads to a way out.
Charging through the smell towards the grate, you find it
resists your attempts to open it.
It's locked.
Locked.
You take a shallow breath and focus on unlocking it as
swiftly as possible.
What about the key that we got?
New stuff in the shop?
Reroll foundation card value.
Oh, bye.
That's one's one use.
Awesome.
One single move.
I love it.
Wait, it reshuffled my cards.
I had such a good hand before.
Dang it.
Um, let's do this one.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Can I get...
What I was gonna do was I was gonna use the mana boost and
then do the double times.
Um, but I don't want it to just...
It won't destroy the double.
Oh good, we got it.
There we go.
Easy peasy.
Minto Gaming?
Never punished?
Nice luck.
It's not luck.
It's believing in the heart of the cards.
Or something like that.
How do I want to...
Let's go to the Ace instead.
Oh, Re-roll!
Oh, fill all available Joker slots.
I just got.
Foundation card value.
Like, what does that?
I'm going to try it.
Oh, neat.
Oh, wait.
It worked for us even.
Curse combo.
Our combo is crazy.
Believing with style.
Wicked combo.
Does it say wicked if I get over 10?
Is that what it is?
I haven't been paying attention.
to the number, I'll be honest.
Wicked win!
Slim pickings here.
Smoking sick style!
Oh yeah.
Nice.
Okay, we just need the last one.
Come on, eight.
Come on, ten.
Yippee!
Wicked!
Dante would hate this game, maybe.
With the grate unlocked, you push it open with haste and
escape the suffocating tunnel.
You rise to your feet and find yourself within a large round
room, coated in gristled chains and entrails.
Oh, yeah.
echoed sounds of dripping coming from below.
Looking down, you realize that a large central chain from
the ceiling plummets down the center of a spiral staircase.
Where are we trying to go?
The consuming darkness conceals just how far the stairs
descend.
You flick your finger alight and begin your descent.
Okay, we have to play solitaire to go down the stairs.
That's fine.
Understandable.
Thank you for giving me a hand that I cannot start with.
Makes sense.
Yeah, to the mid-cafe!
Oh.
To get to my cafe, you do have to go through all of this.
So actually, this is based on a true story.
Believe it or not.
Fact or fiction?
Truth or tale?
Truth!
But the doubt or...
will say tale.
Let's do the king and then the ace.
And then the two and then the three and then the four.
I think that's all I can do.
Two.
Ace.
No king.
Me when I gotta fight zombies and monsters get to a cafe.
Look, it's very exclusive.
We just...
I'm sorry, but it's literally the best of the best.
Ooh, I can either do Jack, Queen, or the not...
We'll do Jack Queen, because we got it.
Oh, and then back to Jack.
Nice.
Truth or tale?
Tale?
But don't pull on it.
Sensitive.
Hmm.
End my turn.
Oh shoot, I could have... Oh no, I wasted that, but that's
okay.
That's fine, I guess.
I should have done the seven.
Dang it.
I'm pulling it.
Don't!
Don't pull my tail.
That's freak behavior.
Pull.
No!
What's wrong with you?
Come on, the game!
We're gaming, we're gaming!
Four, five.
Secret reveal, the secret has been revealed.
Nice.
Yeah!
Save it for after stream.
You think I'm just pulling on my tail after stream?
You think...
That's an after stream activity.
As you make your way down the steps, you notice the chain is
shaken.
A distant whimper echoes louder with each step.
Finally, you see it.
Attached to the chain's end, a bound prisoner weeps as they
hang inverted.
Their blood dripping down into the abyss below.
Don't attack me!
I'm not your enemy!
as you spot them the bound prisoner begins to shake more
violently with a bloody burst a stream of maggots more
maggots pours from their eyes and mouth their cries now
muffled whoa with a visceral crackle of bias and maggot
savagely breaks through the prisoner's chest its long
serpentine body lashes wildly before striking towards you.
Not the mega maggots.
Oh my god.
Oh, what's in the shop?
We got a ring!
5% chance to inflict a critical hit!
That's pretty good.
10% chance to counterattack for three damage!
I think...
How much is a crit, you know?
10% is a higher chance.
But then this is plus 5.
Have we gotten a critical hit?
Yeah, we're 10 short of both.
Crit's usually double.
Counter is good.
I agree.
A counter because we're kind of guaranteed to get hit.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Let's do the 10%.
We can buy this after.
Okay.
Okay, he only has one permanent defense.
What is this?
Screech.
A cacophonous shriek that forces you to drop a random Joker.
And deals three damage.
Wait, that's terrible.
Okay, so what we're going to do then is...
Okay, we're going to use up as much as we can.
We're going to definitely reuse up this re-roll.
So I am going to do this.
do this
will mana wait, change the suit of okay, hold on we'll do
this change the suit I guess it doesn't really matter yeah,
it gets rid of that okay then we'll re wait, then we do this
okay then we attack this or yeah, why not?
It doesn't really matter.
We'll attack this.
Then we do this.
This is the order of operations.
This is the order of operations, everybody.
Oh, I could have used that 10.
Oh, that's okay.
And then I'll mana storm.
And then I will grab two more.
Wombo combo.
Mega maggot failed focus group testing for the English name
of the Capcom game proc way.
Okay, then...
Storm!
Then this.
Then I think that's it.
And I end my turn.
Okay.
It got rid of the thing that would heal us, but...
It is what it is.
It had to be done.
That's no good.
Nice.
We'll save this for when it's not resting.
Oh, man.
Huge bite!
Okay.
Defense.
Defense is up.
More defenses up.
Nice.
Oh, no.
I only have one damage, though.
Oh, we got the counter?
Oh, huge.
I didn't notice.
Thanks, guys.
Okay.
Clean.
I wish we could get more damage in.
I wonder if we should, like, read.
We're not going to get any damage.
I think we can't get any combos.
For this, we'll have to go 7, 6.
Oh, nice, okay.
And we'll save that.
And I...
In my turn!
And then we'll...
4.
This is not going to do anything, but that's okay.
We'll do this.
Nice play.
Thank you.
I like this game.
This game's pretty fun.
I'm not going to lie.
We'll do that.
I feel like we should get rid of that one.
Okay, we'll save that.
Addicting gameplay loop.
It's just like you...
It just...
Itches my brain enough, you know what I mean?
Where I'm like...
Wait, what was this one?
Target a playable card.
We could do this too.
Let's try it.
Oh!
Oh, wait!
He's dead!
We win!
JJ.
I guess I could have saved it, but that's okay.
The Leviathan maggot lets out a shrill squeal before
plummeting into the pit.
The prisoner's corpse dangles a limp way.
You breathe a sigh of relief, taking a moment to gather
yourself.
Then a distant buzzing sound begins to echo through the
spiral stair.
With horror, you peer into the pit to witness the glimmer of
thousands of beady red eyes looking back at you from the
darkness, rising with the sinister hum of shimmering
translucent, wing flies oh my god the buzzing grows louder
as it races at you an enormous disgusting display of eyes
wings and feelers blurring your weary vision oh man what is
it oh it's gonna drip on me no it's gonna suck my blood oh
well okay okay listen up buckaroo i found some good sheesh
so you know that developer who died shannon whatever oh my
god some respect on shannon's Well, I tried to find info on
the symbol carved into those weird daggers she used, and it
looks like it might have ties to an occult group called the
Keepers.
This is like getting like freaky freaky.
Just getting freaky freaky.
It's getting freaky freaky.
It's getting freaky freaky on the Mint Channel channel.
On the Mint Freaky channel.
The Mint Freakum channel.
That's Mint Phantom freaky.
It's getting freaky freaky.
Freaky, freaky.
It's getting freaky, freaky.
That's how we like it.
Oh yeah, made channel.
Same freaky time.
Same freaky place.
Wait, I should get my glasses on.
I haven't put these on in a bit.
Some of you may have never seen these before.
Oh yeah.
Guys, I think she's freaky.
Freak phantom!
In the hiz-out!
What is up, my freaks?
How's it freaking going, you freaks?
Can you wear both these and the swirly glasses, yeah?
Hi, yeah!
Only glasses always.
Wait, now I'm four eyes.
You did not to make fun of me.
Now I'm four eyes.
You did not to call me a nerd.
Wait, now I'm six eyes.
That's even worse.
Wrong toggle.
I'm over it.
Nerd.
I hope you're enjoying this because I ain't stop and now I'm
on a roll, bro.
The captured eye symbol commonly used by the occult group
known as the Keepers, founded in the 12th century.
The infamous alchemist and suspected warlock.
Alcorn will.
Wait, how, wait, oh.
I was going to say we haven't seen that before in here
though yet.
Put on your cat ears.
You can be a four by four.
Oh, because...
Because I would need four ears and four eyes.
I get it.
You're silly.
What was he doing?
Oh, we're fighting.
We're fighting the fly, I forgot.
Vampiric bite that drains you of five health.
Ugh.
Okay.
Let's do...
This?
Manor.
Right, eight.
We can do no more...
Oh, good.
It'll do all the health, though.
He has no permanent health.
A V-tuber played Forbidden Solitaire.
This is what happened to her brain.
Truth or tale, fact or fiction.
Oh!
Ah!
Dodge!
Wait, oh, what did it say?
Evade the next attack.
Okay, so we don't want it to be...
Wait, it's gonna be... Wait, I finally got a good combo
though.
Come on, please!
Please!
No, it's gonna be so good!
Oh wait, no it's not.
I don't have a three.
I'm stupid.
Never mind, it's not so good.
Yeah, whatever.
Yeah, you think you're so cool.
Don't say hi, Minky.
Hi, Miss!
Six eyes, more than enough to see anything that moves.
Also, that ain't!
Thank you so much for the five.
Good to thank you.
Silver, welcome back.
Thank you!
He's resting.
Here we go.
Okay, okay.
Ouch.
Oh, I wish it would give it to me.
Please, I need it!
I didn't need to get...
I didn't need to get those at all, actually.
Oh well.
Good combo.
Magots, that infest cards.
I think I'm gonna refresh.
Yeah, I think that was for the best.
Okay, this is good.
Because we definitely need that.
Good, good.
Oh, good.
Now we completely avoid that.
I would do...
Is this count as an effect, I guess?
the suit lock.
But it doesn't really help us right now because we have no
playable cards, so...
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
The bug is sucking us.
It is!
Uh...
If I do this...
Wait.
Oh, the target card.
Oh, no.
Oh, I can only do...
Okay.
I can do this one.
Wait, it has to be diamonds.
Wait, I'm...
I'm stupid.
It's gotta be diamonds.
I was about to do the wrong thing.
Okay, whatever.
He evades it anyway.
It's fine.
Okay, maggots.
I still don't have a diamond.
Yes.
No six.
Wait, there's a diamond.
Okay, hold on.
Can you target your hand?
It doesn't seem like it.
I think it says target a playable card.
We're so close, though, guys.
We're so close.
I think we can do it here.
Okay.
Oh, and it got rid of the effect, too!
We're so small.
I totally meant to do that.
And I think he is down, baby.
But we're just gonna do overkill.
And...
Take some
money.
Take his money.
Change targeted playable card to your advantage.
I like the lucky number.
Its legs twitch as the overgrown insects' body lies pulped
and torn before you.
It's pearly green Leonard spluttered across the stone steps.
Don't slip!
Why did we have to kill him on the steps?
Finally, it is done.
Yeah, we swatted that fly.
Yeah, we took care of that bozo.
Oh, oops, my bad.
Okay.
You move hastily down the steps.
Your heart filled with eager determination to be rid of this
foul place.
As you descend, you are at last greeted with the sight of a
vine-encrusted tree.
door at the bottom of the stairs this must be the way
forward as you make your way toward the door a familiar
chain dragging stomping sound begins to pound the steps
above the ground shakes with each step as it swiftly closes
the distance you must hide quickly I'm hiding quickly avoid
detection again okay let's it's this one right yeah I will
buy it oh it's a You think we can put another gemmy in here?
Oh my god, my middle finger is so blinged out, though.
Too tight.
I feel like we should just buy this just to have it.
It might be good if we...
Actually, we'll see if we have to fight the guy.
We'll get it.
You know what I mean?
Me, thank you!
Oh, okay, it's this thing again.
Oh gosh, okay.
This is fine.
I will use...
Wait, one, two, three, four...
Yeah, I will use this.
Because we have to clear out this whole thing, so I think
it's probably better to use it than not.
That's all I can do.
Save it for later.
It'll never go away.
Do I use the key?
No!
Wait, wait.
I'm gonna be a little cheeky.
My bad.
Smart.
Yeah.
We know that it only becomes...
Like, it's alerted, but...
It eventually, yeah, it eventually goes down.
Just like that.
I'm not at use on that ace.
I guess I could have.
Not a good card.
Wow!
Nice.
Undo.
It's okay.
Must have been the wind.
Exactly.
He knows nothing.
Nor will he ever know nothing.
He will never know anything.
I kind of want to know what this does to my advantage.
What will it change to?
Ah, wait, oh, change the targeted card to...
Oh, for some reason I thought it would change this.
Oh, I wonder if on the...
We'll save it.
I was about to do it on this so that we could get these
cards, but I'm glad I didn't.
I'm glad I held out.
Ah, wait, we can.
Well, I can also grab this.
Wait, actually, this would be better.
Oops.
Don't look.
That's mean.
Do it!
No, we're so close to beating this one.
Oh look, it's now for longer.
Oh, it's expecting me for longer.
That's kind of freaky.
Okay, okay.
Oh, I wonder.
Can I get away with it again?
He doesn't know anything.
There we go.
See?
No!
Can I do it again?
I'm rage-baiting the monster.
Easy.
Yeah.
Must have been the win.
Nothing here.
Solitaire gear.
What was that noise?
Nothing here.
Must have been the win.
Just a box.
Rapidly, you descend the steps and find a crevice to hide
away in.
The massive creature descends quickly and violently, making
it to the bottom floor movements after you.
It sniffs the air as it stomps around the room.
He's gonna find me!
There sure is a lot of wind in this dungeon!
Whose footprints are these?
Searching.
Oh my god, shocking.
Searching!
Oh.
A distant cry echoes from above.
And the hulking mass swiftly turns its attention towards the
sound.
Aggressively, it turns and races up the steps.
Its chains loudly scraping against the stone.
At last, it's gone.
Quietly, you make your way towards the trap door.
You notice a familiar symbol in lock beneath the vine-coated
surface.
Oh!
You pull out the key you found in the prisoner earlier.
On the prisoner earlier, inserting it.
As you try and turn the key inside the lock, you feel the
crunchy web of vines restraining its movement.
You must clear these vines with haste.
Okay.
Oh, now we have vines.
And new stuff in the shop.
What's this?
Ice shards!
same value?
I feel like any card, any Joker card I'm gonna buy.
He's crunchy.
Now what do we have here?
Playing a face-up card will untangle the nearest vine.
Oh my gosh, Emily you scared me.
So I went back and did more digging into the studio and
found this news clip from when they were first starting up.
Apparently they were originally working on some kind of
open-world fantasy game thing?
Skyrim?
Sounds fun as hell, actually.
Why didn't they wind up releasing this?
You may know him as the creative mind behind the
best-selling Drake Flame Chronicles novels your kids are
reading on the playground.
Drake Flame!
Flip!
Now, the book author Lucas B.
Hart has started the new technology company, Hart-Blake
Interactive, to bring his fantasy books to life on home
computers.
In books, you can peek into the life of someone living in a
fantastical world of Dragon's Adventure.
There are four dungeons and then a big thing.
Oh, thank you.
Has the potential to let you actually live that life for
yourself.
It finally came through!
Our team of computer technology experts are hard at work
creating hundreds of three-dimensional buildings.
Wildlife and fantastical creatures to populate a full-scale
computer simulation.
If every fantasy enthusiast's dream come true.
With graphics technology coming as far as it has, you don't
even have to imagine these things anymore.
You experience them yourself.
in a realistic simulation crafted by advanced algorithms.
You don't just mindlessly kill monsters like in most games.
Though you can certainly do that too.
In Drake Flame Chronicles.
I mean it when I say that.
I can't say it.
You can literally do that.
Drake Flame Chronicles.
You can rule your own kingdom.
That was my favorite.
You can start a farm on the frontiers of civilization and
use the profits from it to begin a tavern business that you
then franchise.
You can invest in fantasy real estate.
You can...
Thank you so much also for the...
wear a glamour of his body and then take his family for your
own and raise it until you crown your son as the next heir
of your inheritance.
Wow.
It's truly groundbreaking.
Groundbreaking.
And the Todd Howard of his time.
I believe that we have only begun to scratch the surface of
what is possible in the video game.
Oh my god, Kojima.
Great Sling Chronicles.
The video game is currently planned to hit store shelf by I
like how Emily says this game or it sounds fun, we got to
see two models.
We got to see, like, the dragon.
And, like, that was it.
Oh.
Very cool.
In fact, I will go like this.
Combo, combo, wombo, combo.
As with most game announcements nowadays.
Yeah.
Emily totally falls for the pie in the sky, bitch.
You know what, though?
I get it.
I get it because it's not that I also do that, but at the
same time, I want to have, like, faith in, like, you know,
fun things.
So I also get excited and something is promised to me, you
know, or rather when they're talking about things.
Like, I would rather believe that somebody has faith in
their game for it to be cool.
Then not.
Does that make sense?
In on A!
I need to really unlock this place.
You could say the pitch was beyond belief.
Imagine if it was like Tencent's gonna be lame.
No!
I could never!
Wait a second, I just realized, can I even...
I can't unlock this at the...
Wait, I'm...
Wait, this is kind of bad, actually.
Playable card to your advantage.
Wait, this is actually bad?
Okay, I just have to play this floor.
Evil Minta.
That's what they're calling me.
That's what everybody's saying.
Ah, thank goodness!
Still not great though.
Yikes.
Okay, uh...
Not good.
We're pulling out all the stops.
Nope.
Wait.
Even still.
Nope.
It's so close.
Wait, wait, Troy.
So, I tried.
I tried.
There was an attempt.
Actually, we'll do this one because that'll help towards
that.
um next card
that will help towards that okay i really gotta pay
attention to this thing because it locks me in he sounds
like a snake when he dies oh
oh good good good good good okay okay okay we may be better
now we might be be able to win this now.
That one really, like, screwed us over, though.
Yeah, we got this, maybe?
I could have gone for the Jack and the Queen, but...
Jack, Queen.
King.
No.
Oh, wait, Ace.
Take this.
Oh, dang it.
What's this one do?
Oh, yeah, this is just our wild card.
That will be good in a pinch.
Okay, very good.
Do I want a mana storm?
I think it's worth it.
Wombo combo.
Wait, maybe we don't need him.
Maybe we're too good at the game.
2A king?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
Like, I don't want to waste this, but it's only two at the
same time.
Whatever.
It's fine.
That was a crazy combo.
And now, since these are right next to each other...
Easy!
We can save that for a fight.
Let the vines clear.
You try once again twisting the key inside the lock.
Wait, I don't...
I got an achievement.
I didn't see what it was.
As you turn it, you hear the tumblers lie and unlocking the
door.
You pull open the latch and find a ladder leading down into
a cavernous pit, swallowed in darkness.
You step onto the ladder, hearing the wood creak under your
weight.
As you attempt to descend quietly, you shut the latch
behind.
on to clubs yeah so we what we the first one was spade and
then we did hearts and now we're on clubs as you step off
the ladder your breath quivers at the sight of the vast
overgrown labyrinth of leafy hedges before you gathering
your courage you set foot into the maze i kind of wish they
allowed you to choose your paths but i think that would make
the game like hundred times longer.
They're like, don't worry about it.
Well, we'll pick for you.
We'll pick for you, dummy.
You're dummy.
You're stupid.
We'll pick for you.
Don't worry, you're sweet little head about it.
I'm trying to tell you that's just not possible in the time
frame you've given the team, Lucas.
Not possible?
Nothing's impossible, Shannon.
Like I've always said, you guys can
If you had told me I'd have a published and successful
fantasy novel series, I'd have told you that was impossible.
Yet here we are!
Yeah, that's great, Lucas.
But what I'm saying is that this new modular spellcasting
system is taking the team and I way more time to develop
than we anticipated.
And we're already behind on the dynamic kingdom economy and
NPC life pursuits.
If we continue our current course, we're not going to make a
December launch.
That's just the reality of it.
so we're just gonna give up hell no fighting spirit shannon
shannon not give up lucas we might just have to make some
compromises probably cut one of these features or ask future
software another budget extension those are the two options
as i see them without performing miracles this guy triple a
developer pov no No, he cares way too much about the game.
For it to be the POV of that.
I've seen it with my own eyes.
I believe in us.
I really wish you could too.
I like the music down here.
Okay, awesome.
Queen.
King.
Oh, wombo combo.
I'm trying not to use my...
Unless I get a new one, you know?
Don't say it.
King.
Six.
Five.
Two.
Six.
Revealed!
Come on, I just need a 10, please.
Or a queen?
I didn't know!
I thought it would be able to- I thought it would let me
choose.
Oh!
Victory, but barely.
This guy only speaks in inspirational chatbot messages.
It's kind of like Darmok, for those who know.
I don't know.
Exhausted from your travels, you stop to compose yourself,
leaning against a nearby hedge.
Oh, don't lean against the hedge!
There's gonna be something in the hedge!
The Niminator.
As your weary body rests upon the leafy hedge, it begins to
sink into its embrace.
Deeper and deeper.
You let yourself sink, as you cannot help but be taken in by
its comfort.
Oh my god, it's gonna smooch me.
Peering into the brush, comfort is swiftly supplanted by
terror a ghastly hollow face stares back at you dozens of
hungry roots protruding from its skin the face gasps out of
pleading croak you try tearing yourself away from the hedge
but grasping sharp branches and vines constrain your efforts
attempting to pull you back in oh i like when the music gets
back to like chill what's in the shop what's this extra
refresh oh dang we have so much
increases joker frequency by 25 percent okay you know what
i'll buy it i wonder if we'll get another one if we can
unlock another one fight a constricting mass of vines that
binds cards and deals three damage this guy is beefy but he
has no protection thing so might be okay maybe
which three should i use we'll do this one wait how much is
it three damage i guess it's better to take no damage than
not Yeah, now I should.
Um, let's do...
This?
Eight, seven.
Eight, nine?
Okay, good...
Oh, ten?
I'm not gonna use that, but I will use that.
Joker, king...
Two, three, holy cow!
Oh, shoot.
I didn't mean to use that.
Grab that.
Whoa!
Holy cow.
Our damage is 17!
Um...
Oh, we'll do three, four, five, six.
21 damage!
Go!
Counter-attack.
The enemy is about to counter.
Hover over the enemy's next action for details.
Counter-attack for five damage if you attack in this turn.
For five?
Oops.
Wait, I guess I'm gonna attack now.
Uh...
Wait, what's this do?
Can you... Oh, the refresh.
So no damage, but I already did the damage.
So I'm kind of screwed.
It's okay.
We'll only take...
We'll only take three damage.
It's okay, probably.
Probably.
New set.
I'm wondering if I want to take this, though.
The extra refresh.
You know?
Like a BB.
I mean, I think we're going to beat this guy.
But...
I'm gonna get rid of this one you don't really need it and
I'm gonna take this and then I'll refresh ouch times three
okay because I can use this for another time too and I have
the magic missile magical missile Oh, we got that one back.
That's funny.
Wow.
Oh, we're about to, like, murder this guy, for real.
He's even...
Oh, he's resting.
Maybe I should have left it alone.
But it's okay.
Um...
I could use something like a lucky number.
Maybe I would just...
Yeah.
Okay, we're about to murder this thing.
I want to do overkill though, it's kind of fun.
Re-roll!
Dang it.
Yes!
Re-roll!
He's doing the counter.
It's fine, he's gonna die, like, right now.
Replace this Joker with a clone of the targeted Joker.
Stop, he's already dead.
Growns of anguish beckon as you finally sever yourself from
the hedge's grasp, hastily scrambling backwards, the leaves
bristle as if daring you to approach again.
You cannot rest in this place.
to immortality don't you want to live don't you want to meow
forever that's the joker joker you push away the nightmarish
visions of what you've witnessed spiraling in your skull and
refocus your attention on the journey ahead one step at a
time you proceed to navigate this maze of misery keeping a
safe distance from its voracious walls forever meow i want
to be forever for meow twin ravens remove up the two random
playable cards from the tableau a guy
we're searching the labyrinth oh major breakthrough you'd
never guess who that shannon lady is related to tell me
emily tell me
shannon's grandfather is a guy named cedric sierra a
practicing member of the keepers so So of course I traced
his family origins.
I think Emily's gonna die.
I traced his family origins and he's related to the original
founder, a guy named Alcorn Wulet.
They're all related to one another.
They're like that one family.
The one, the ones that kept it in the, they kept it in the
family.
One big happy occult family oh sweet home Alabama the
Habsburgs yes yes that royal family whoa that is a wait what
the heck is this thing oh is that the dog look at him why
doesn't the dog get in our blindfold
dog not allowed to be in the he's sitting so politely i
don't like when dogs sit like that because i don't want to i
need a sensor or something dog's face is so cute though
oh my goodness thanks for that emily how did she find their
family photo where is she digging okay this sucks Please.
Thank you.
Oh, shh.
Oh, well, that's okay.
Comebo.
That shh, you messed up.
How do you guys know that's like my favorite sketch ever?
Is that Sheila's dog?
You've talked about it before.
I know.
How do you remember?
So funny.
We shall king.
And then we'll ace.
No!
I want the birds!
We'll do a magic missile at this guy.
I don't want that.
Wait, I have to take it eventually though.
What if I do this?
There we go.
Nice.
I don't think I need it right now, you know?
I haven't died from lack of health so far.
I've only died from...
Running out of cards.
Isn't there a bird one you love too?
I love birds.
It's a good sketch.
It really is.
If you haven't seen it, look up.
What do you look up even?
Drop out.
Sheila's dog.
I think you can find it there.
Nice.
You know what?
I'm gonna use this just for fun, see you soon.
Secrets revealed!
Sakoyama, he's like my comedy Oshi.
He's so funny.
If I could do a collab with Dropout, like a Game Changer, it
would be so awesome.
I've always thought like, oh my gosh, you know what?
You know what Game Changer is missing?
VTubers?
game changer episodes somehow in vr where they're like in vr
chat they have vtubers involved and like they're little i
don't know furry mascots or something vtubers you know what
they're missing vtubers that vtuber me phantom me i said it
first here choose me pick me
Game changer, but you're on one of those iPad robots.
Savingly identical paths grow more familiar as you navigate.
Slowly but surely, you forge your way forward.
You hear the blissful sound of water nearby.
At least, could be a reprieve from this maze drawn near?
No.
What if, though, there's mermaids?
The pulse of your pounding heart skips as you turn the
corner and witness the twinkle of a spring in the distance.
Mermaids, mermaids, mermaids.
Steiner better get busy.
Yeah, that guy better get busy.
Mermaids!
Joyously, you carry your feet toward its grace when the
ceiling high above begins to tremble.
Uh-oh, is it that chain guy again?
Cute and smart ghost say, what?
That ain't fake, thank you so much for the fun, good dude!
Sam says, raid your hand.
Sam says, touch your nose.
Sam says, send a soup with a mint bag.
You didn't say...
You did say Sam says...
No!
Wait, I want the mermaids.
Give us the mermaids!
Oh no, it is this guy again!
What the heck?
Why is he digging through the ceiling?
But the violent crash...
Uh-oh, I wasted my mana attack.
Rix tumbled outward as a gargantuan figure lands before you.
wrestle as it rises and you realize you recognize this large
looming creature.
Samson!
It sniffs the air and bears its toothy maul having finally
found its escaped prisoner.
Uh oh.
I have one.
It's okay.
We have a bunch of stuff here.
Oh, what's in the shop?
Bloodstone 2.
Increases health by 10!
Sure.
What about my pinky?
Guys, we are so blinged out.
Look at us.
We look awesome.
We're finally fighting this guy.
Well, shoot.
Maybe, well, I didn't have the ace before, so...
Oh!
Why is it in real?
I didn't read what he was gonna do!
Yikes.
That wasn't good.
At least he's...
Oh, he's got two permanent defense.
Well, we can use that already.
Streamers don't read.
It's me!
I'm streamer!
This one will unlock this one, so we'll do that.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, we can do that.
What if I get rid of this?
Dang.
It didn't help us at all.
But I think it did actually hurt him.
I'm like, do I want to...
I have a good combo going here.
So I'm like, do I want to...
Ah!
Okay.
He's going to stomp me.
A gigantic stomp that forces you to drop a random Joker and
deals 8 damage!
Uh, we don't want 8 damage, so we're gonna try and get rid
of that as much as possible.
Let's...
8 damage is humongous.
Let's shuffle before I do anything.
Use 4 normal Joker's in a single level.
Wow.
Okay.
Okay, so now we're only taking two damage.
Much better than than the previous amount.
And we're doing like eight damage at least.
And I think I'll do the re-roll after this.
I think so.
Oh, but there's like a permanent damage in there or like a
damage thing in there.
I'm like, do we gamble it?
Oh, yeah, I should use my Joker.
You're right, because I'm going to drop it.
So, okay.
Yes, the skull car.
Okay, now we're good.
Now we're good.
Block a huge hit.
Six plus damage.
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
That was huge.
What's this one?
Suit locks, fasten upon cards, cat.
causing two damage well i can block the damage luckily
oh huge nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
nice nice i'm gonna save this
i end my turn ouch okay he's resting
what's this one The clone of a targeted...
I don't have another Joker.
The counter.
Oh, we countered.
Freak gaming.
Yeah, baby!
I'm trying to decide what I want to do.
Like, if I want to grab this and hope that I can get
something else.
But I think it's better to just end.
He's still resting.
Nice!
Okay, cool.
I wish I had another...
Joker!
There's one here.
Like, way in the depths.
This will only do one damage.
Sad.
Wait!
Nine!
Let's...
Ten!
Alright, that's about it.
Almost out of mana storm again.
Yeah, yeah, we are.
Okay, we deflected that.
Nice, we deflected that.
Okay.
Now we need...
Now we need to...
Remove all duplicate playable cards with the same value.
What is that?
I'm gonna try this.
Wait.
Oh?
Oh, it's not playable, I guess.
Oh, okay.
that sucks.
We're not, we're gonna take mega damage, you guys.
DT mega damage.
Which ends up being pretty doo-doo.
Here we go.
Or?
I could shuffle real quick.
Use the duplicate before he forces you to drop it.
That's That's true.
Or we would drop, we would lose one anyway, so...
I'm gonna shuffle.
I think it was safer, too.
Whoa!
It worked!
Whatever that was!
You unlock this special Joker, turn all cards face up!
Whoa!
You rise to your feet, bruised and bloody, but still living.
Looking down at the defeated beast, you can't help but feel
sorry for it as it weakly gasps for air.
That was awesome.
Vines extend from a nearby hedge and grasp at the creature,
pulling it towards the verdant mass of leaves.
You leave the monster to its fate.
Approaching the water, you notice it is an enormous lake,
encircled by hedges on all sides.
There are definitely mermaids in here.
Save for a single opening directly opposite.
Alas, the maze doesn't end here, though you welcome the
change of view.
You gather yourself before stepping into the lake, prepared
to swim across.
I joined streamerly lay behind me though.
Hello!
Thanks for joining at all.
The maze feeds.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Traverse the lake.
We're, um...
Shannon the venom it's it's getting there it's still going
way over the memory it's sorry Lucas but I'm kind of in the
middle of something we can chat after lunch whoa what's this
I've never seen this before forbidden solitaire sounds
gnarly where'd this come from put that down oh got it got it
sorry not shannon uh so what is it some side project of
yours yeah something like that it's nothing to worry about
i'd just like to keep it close yeah totally totally i get
that the thing is we just have a tight deadline is all i
don't think we can afford to be working on things i'm fully
aware it's nothing you need to worry about i'm not spending
Shannon is related to the cold.
It's her fault!
Or hear it or think about it again.
It's Shannon's fault.
Yeah, very inconspicuous.
I don't want to lose my train of thought here.
I didn't.
I...
Okay.
I'll just...
Let's get over here now.
Yeah, that'll be great work.
I thought it was Lucas's fault.
Shannonator.
Oh,
dang it, I was hoping it would get this one.
A whale.
Now I get it.
I guess maybe I could have gotten this.
Whatever.
It's fine.
We'll make it.
Probably.
This is like a dick thing to play for real, though.
Acquired.
He probably got so curious about it, he played it himself.
And then all chaos ensued.
You know?
You're good at this game?
I feel good at this game.
Eee.
Um, I'm gonna...
Pick you.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
No, we just need to...
Get a five?
There we go.
Minto playing Balatro too.
Imagining eldritch beings burning an evil CD relic.
I know, right?
Like, we have to.
We are an evil cult, but we must get with the times.
Shannon, we bestow you with our evil video game to spread
our cult.
Yes.
We ask you, Shannon, to have the children play solitaire, to
kill them for our cult.
They need to spread their memes somehow, man.
It's so true.
Like the ring, but video games.
The lake's far edge approaches.
Your body aches from the strain of the swim, barely keeping
your head above water.
You hoist your body onto the shore, breathing deeply.
You rest for a moment as the water drips off you, as the
tension in your sore muscles ebbs.
Does anyone have eyes on Halligan?
Finally, you.
rise and face the opening in the hedge wall, stealing
yourself for the journey ahead.
Oh my god!
Before you can take a single step, you feel something coil
itself around your foot, yanking you back into the water.
The Mermaid!
Bubbles obscure your vision as you're dragged beneath the
lake's surface, but through them you spot a hideous, fanged
jaw-eyes of a lithe and grotesque man-like, man!
Where's my lady?
We're shopping.
Manablast.
Remove all playable cards in the same row as the target
card.
Costs 20 mana.
I'll cancel for now.
So lame.
50.
And Venom.
A deadly spray of poison that clings to cards.
We're gonna get to the light, baby.
Let's try turning all cards.
Oh.
No, we don't need to.
Oh, wait, I'm so stupid.
Oh, okay, this is fine, though.
Ouch!
Wait, I get hurt by them?
Uh-oh.
We'll do this one instead.
Ow.
That's all it did.
I'm like, do I want to re-roll?
Not the damage!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, okay, while they're on the... Oh, okay, so...
Let me draw a card.
Oh, I didn't read it right.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, okay, okay.
This is fine.
Um...
Mighty thrash that inflicts five damage.
Okay.
Oh, we want to get rid of these, though, for sure.
So I'm going to reroll...
And one more time.
You know what?
This is fine.
We can do some more...
We can get some more combo damage stuff.
If only I had an ace...
Okay, I'm going to reroll one more time.
I'm sure you'll meet your ideal mermaid someday.
Oh, yes!
Okay, we can get rid of those.
Okay, now we only have the one damage to worry about.
And the five...
Okay, that should block everything, I think.
Degradification, I know, right?
Awesome, we'd love to see it.
I'm not gonna take that for now.
It could give us more damage.
Oh yeah, this one can purify the cards, can't it?
Okay, we'll save it for when we have more poison, I think.
I don't want to keep taking damage though.
Okay, I'll use it.
Ouch, ouch.
There we go.
Yippee!
Okay, now...
I feel like I should refresh, but at the same time I want
that...
We'll just refresh though.
Hi!
Okay.
Target card.
It doesn't really matter.
It also cleanses some of the effects.
We'll just do this.
Yippee!
Okay.
Cool.
It doesn't really matter.
That's okay.
Good play.
No poisons.
I'm gonna save this even though...
It could have given us something.
Okay, we're getting the five damage, so we'll do that.
In fact, I'll even shuffle.
Getting an extra refresh.
We'll do that too.
Okay, now we'll take one damage.
Only one damage.
Nice, nice.
Yeah.
We're almost there.
I feel like we could do it, but at the same time, I'm
scared.
This is the poison.
I want these!
Ow!
Okay.
You know what?
Screw you.
Oh, I didn't...
You know what?
Screw you, I don't care.
I probably should have gotten rid of anything.
Whatever.
You know what?
It's fine.
I was thinking I should have probably gotten rid of...
Or done the cards... The moves that I could do first.
But you know what?
Whatever.
I just need one more damage on this guy.
Please!
And he's cooked.
Yeah, I fired prematurely.
I was too excited about it.
Delay the enemy for one turn.
Oh, I like that.
As you deliver a final blow to the Viper, you feel a wave of
dizziness alongside sharp agony as the dying creature's fang
reflexively pierce into your flesh.
Finally, it falls limp.
The serpent begins...
What's happening to my foot?
Is that blood or what is that?
What's in my foot?
The serpent begins to sink its fangs, dragging you under
with it.
Thinking fast, you tear them from your flesh and thrash your
way back towards the surface.
His dogs are out.
Why didn't you wear shoes to the labyrinth?
You idiot.
I'm just gonna go into this dungeon barefoot.
What the hell?
Am I wearing any clothes?
Thought the grippers gotta keep those safe Like you could
have put on sandals or anything You emerge once again on the
lake's shore Gasping for breath as you drag your body away
from the treacherous banks You stumble to your feet, your
head still spinning With stubborn determination you hobble
forward into the labyrinth
This guy is...
Oh, hello, Emily, my sister So info is somewhat sparse on
the keepers, but I found a few more details on some occult
sites.
Looks like they were founded at some point in the 12th
century, blah blah blah blah, but they collect and keep
demonic artifacts, that's the name.
They pass the artifacts down from generation to generation.
That would explain the daggers.
But why?
What kind of a freaky ritual was Shannon performing?
Oh my god, the demonic artifact of video game!
Whoa!
How is he getting Wi-Fi down here?
No, no, we're playing...
We are playing the Forbidden Solitaire.
So we're actually just on our desktop, like, chilling.
Aw, mean.
What's this one?
Delay?
Oh, yeah.
Well, that doesn't really help me right now, but...
Yeah, it's a game within a game.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
I never thought the toilet game was so demonic.
The toilet game?
Are you playing solitaire on the toilet?
You shouldn't do that.
You shouldn't play things on the...
You shouldn't look at your phone.
You shouldn't sit on the toilet for too long.
You're gonna get hemorrhoids.
So true, Queen.
It's true!
Facts.
So true, Minto.
How do you know that?
I read about it on the internet.
I read about it.
I did my research.
But it's so comfy.
Sasuke.
You can also get Pink Eye.
Wait, how do you get Pink Eye?
Oh, I came through!
With Streamlabs backed up, it means I could donate in
stealth and secrecy, not because I couldn't find my wallet.
Minto Togo and Minto Fumo had it and were trying to order
dojins.
So many dojins.
No, they've gained sentience!
How?
I cast the spell so they wouldn't.
Did you read about it while on the toilet?
Now wouldn't that have been divine intervention?
I think we can do this one.
Okay, now we just need a six!
Oh man, don't say it!
Don't say it!
This game is like, how is it...
I mean, I've been doing so many numbers.
But why does it always come down to 6-7?
Paths seem to blend together as you continue to trace the
maze walls, attempting to formulate a mental map while your
head's on a pivot.
You turn around, you've been here before.
You know it, you've been here before.
the head just seemed to bloom as your vision blurs while
your brain throbs against your skull you look down and
notice your fang wound is bubbling with a bright viscous
liquid oh we are so it's so poison it's so over for us you
realize now that your fate may have been already been sealed
your eyes wander your head spins faster and faster your mind
races you're going to die here how is it i'm a wizard i
don't have like a A heal spell.
You die.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm bursting the sky again.
It's whiz over.
Oh no!
My gem shattered.
Revive gem.
Revives you with 10 health on death.
Single use.
Okay.
Wait, what's this one again?
The mana blast.
Remove all playable cards in the same row as the target
card.
Cost 20 mil.
You know what?
I will use it.
I'll buy it.
Wait, how much is this?
50.
What do you think I should do?
Eyeball?
He's no help at all.
I will see if I die.
We could be fine.
Let's fight.
You are awesome.
Anyway, thank you.
Name every number.
I don't think you want that.
What does this do, though?
Chaos.
I'm scared of it.
Maybe at least...
Oh, no.
Okay.
No, there's more!
Okay, we're getting rid of them, though.
Which is kind of nice.
We'll just guard ourselves or whatever happens.
happens.
I wonder if it'll destroy it.
Got rid of those locks right away.
Yeah, we're dead, baby.
I'm kind of curious what it does, though.
What's wrong with them?
Oh, they're cards.
Oh, I should have gone up instead No!
Wait, oh This one will create a Joker I will delay him Yeah,
you You sleep for two seconds
Maybe we can get rid of this one Oh, yes!
Yuppie!
Okay
Those are not the original card numbers.
Oh, they weren't!
Okay, okay.
Yeah, maybe they exploded or something of ours.
What was happening here?
Oh.
Yeah, I'll take that.
Oh, minus 10!
Defense card.
Gain three temporary defense.
Guggy.
I don't really have anything to do, though.
Okay.
Oh, he's gonna swipe me.
Ehh, 10 damage!
Okay.
We're at 5 damage.
What's this one doing?
Oh, the bad effects, that's right.
I only got rid of...
Oh, dang, there's so many in there.
That's so mean.
It is so mean, isn't it?
Oh, but...
What we could do is...
Oh, he also gained it, I just realized.
Okay, okay.
Nothing ever is just for me, right?
Everything also benefits him.
This guy... Stop mooching off of me, huh?
Get your own defense card.
Or something.
I'm not getting a really good hand though here, am I?
The red ones are tainted.
Yeah, yeah.
my health is still okay though it's just not great our cards
are not so awesome in fact i'll use that on this one so that
we can
uh-huh i kind of want to get rid of the the this but we have
the block we'll block it
oh what are they gonna do they're gonna explode they're
gonna explode wait i think we killed it though
nice crit
stumble forward hope is reignited as you spot a humble
wooden shack at the mazes and why would we trust anything
literally anything in this maze alas it seems you may live
to witness the end of this labyrinthian devilry.
You feel the sting of your wound festering, your head
pulsing as you drag your feet towards the shack's entrance.
Yeah, the shack must be fine.
Anybody who lives here is absolutely friendly.
As seen as every other creature in this labyrinth.
The door shakes stubbornly as you pull against it.
Lacked.
I'm like been wanting to stop playing, but at the same time,
I've...
Sorcerers, trinket.
I love trinkets.
Draw better stock cards on puzzle levels.
Wow, my gosh.
Can I get rid of them once I...
No.
Oh, no, our poison!
Oh, my gosh.
Are you serious?
No, please.
Wait, this is the worst.
Okay, here we go.
This is terrible.
Oh my god!
I'm really gonna bleed out here!
Please, game!
Give me something!
Oh, I should have done the 2.
I'm such an idiot.
Wait, I can undo.
We undo?
Uh...
Okay, okay, okay.
You see that?
You saw that?
That was pretty sick, wasn't it?
Nice, nice.
Yes, yes.
Okay, now we have no poison.
Thank you.
Wicked combo.
I still need two clovers though.
It is a clover though.
Not yet.
All the solitaire practice paid off?
Yeah, it's totally...
No!
Oh!
Yes!
Nice!
Okay.
Now we won't bleed out, hopefully.
Shoot, I spoke too soon.
Now we just...
I was about to say, now we just need a son.
How?
How does it keep happening?
Guys, we really can't escape it.
The ram shackle door finally gives away and creaks open.
Revealing a cacophony of potion bottles and bruise lining
the walls.
In the corner of the room you spot a cauldron in what
appears to be some kind of recipe book.
An apothecary.
Perhaps here a cure can be brewed.
You may yet evade death.
Oh!
Then a sound.
of clattering.
You peer to the other side of the shack and observe a
shriveled, lanky figure tinkering away in the corner.
Very friendly.
You're far too weak to defend yourself in this state, but
there's no time to waste.
With a hush step, you creep towards the cauldron.
Oh, are we sneaking again?
Sneak past the figure.
Of course we are.
I found it!
Buried in some broken link occult conspiracy PDF, but I
tracked down the file.
wasn't easy.
You're welcome.
So get this.
There's this old ritual involving two daggers called animus
transfer whatever.
They're animorphs.
That was used to transfer a soul into an inanimate object.
I think you can guess what it entails.
It rhymes with shmai shmai shmauking.
Wait, what?
gosh Emily you're really not making this easy for me what
this is not tick tock you don't need to censor it what that
this is droods dude Emily is like dedicated her life to
finding this info honestly I'm like really impressed at the
amount of info she's found and dug up within like the hours
we've been playing this game She's trying to dodge YouTube
censorship.
Oh, she's so thoughtful like that.
Oh, and you know who it's attributed to?
Alcorn Willett, founder of the Keepers.
Boom!
Damn, Emily, you're so good at this.
No wonder your mom's favorite.
Yes, thank you, thank you.
She's so cocky.
Not cocky.
Quirky.
Wow.
Oh, step one.
Preparation.
step two transferal so you gouge your eyes out to be put in
the egg wow everybody wants to go in the egg everybody
everybody oh this is like this is awful this is this is
really terrible
I think I'm gonna use this oh nice it did get one of them
rid of one oh but i got another one though no oh now we have
three again no let's oh wait hold on i might be a genius oh
wait i messed up i'm silly i never mind we're fine a top and
alien altar admits unknown chanting and forgotten rites and
old gods captured soul ever on, faded account.
Six, seven.
You're like, uh, Sisyphus.
But forced to six, seven.
Ouch!
That scared me.
No!
Well, we can take this on anytime.
I wish, though, we could get rid of this.
Seriously?
Ah, you suck, game.
You suck.
Evil, evilness.
Oh, thank you.
Please, please.
Please, please, please.
I don't want to die.
Oh, I have to.
I have to.
Please, please, please.
Oh, I should have done that nine.
Wait, I can undo.
Yeah, that was the better choice.
That was the better choice.
Come on, VTuber.
You can do it.
I'm doing it.
Don't bring
my makeup so nice.
Oh, guys.
There's another.
Oh gosh, we either die by being caught or we bleed out
Please It was once again 6-7 But it saved us this time
How does this keep happening?
Miraculously, you made it to the cauldron Without drawing
any attention Have her faded to 6-7.
Maybe I should play the lottery or something with the 6-7.
6-7 will save the world.
Yeah, I'm just too good.
Grabbing the recipe book, you begin to pour through its
pages.
Pain surges through your body.
She's gonna catch us, I believe.
She's gonna see us read in the book.
All she has to do is turn around.
She's gonna see us read in the book, and then all my sneak
in was for nothing.
You're running out of time.
You focus your eyes, attempting to scan the pages.
vision finally you found it lake serpent antivinum now all
you have to do is brew it
okay we're shopping joker eyes change targeted wait i
already have this no wait oh change targeted playable card
to a joker i'll buy that yeah
really was it like that before
Ouch.
Okay, team.
I'm going to level with you.
The company is in bad shape.
Why?
We've missed a few milestones.
In fact, we blew past Christmas.
The guys at FutureSoft are a bit upset.
And things are looking a bit...
dire.
No!
But that's why I've gathered my warriors here today.
My warriors.
Are we going to let a few setbacks...
Get us down or we're going to come up with a game plan to
beat the odds and win the day.
Yes, sir The floor is yours team Who's got ideas me, sir?
Has future soft agreed to increase our budget and timeline?
No, they have not like I said though guys.
We're looking for solutions here anyone Wait ideas big ideas
wait wait wait wait.
I'm an ideas gal how long do we have before the wells run
dry solutions ladies and gentlemen we got to get out of this
problem mindset anyone else Gary Gary I know you why is
ignoring her Lucas are we getting paid this money there's a
lot of ways to be paid what are you talking about what are
you talking about there's experience Lucas!
Rattlero.
Lucas, are we getting great this month?
Real question.
Not great.
What do we got?
Oh, come on.
I don't want this.
You know what, though?
We'll do it so we can get some health back.
I think it's worth right now.
Yippee!
Oh god, they're getting paid in exposure!
Look at!
Oh!
I'll do it.
Dang it.
Dang it!
Ouch.
Uh-oh.
Ouch!
Okay,
we did the secret!
Ouch!
Six!
That was close.
He was just ignoring her.
You hastily decant your concoction into a nearby bottle and
without hesitation begin to drink.
What if it's supposed to?
You're supposed to pour it on the wound and you drink it.
What if there was something already in here and now you're
going to turn into like a spider I don't know as the pungent
cocktail slides down your throat your vision clears and the
throbbing pain starts to subside you breathe a sigh of
relief before remembering where you are quickly you check
your surroundings oh looking behind you you see the figure
is now gone but in the corner they occupied you now notice
an emblazoned door was that blood on the ground softly you
step towards the door Topical?
I thought it said tropical.
The diamond!
Yeah!
As you reach to open it, you hear quiet footsteps approach
you from behind!
Of course.
I see I told you this was gonna happen.
You spin around to behold the towering wrinkled hag!
Vatorra!
No!
Now lunging toward you, two clovers growing out of shriveled
eye sockets rustled in bloodless.
point once you unlock this door.
Oh, awesome!
Thank you.
We'll unlock it and then we'll...
How long have I been playing?
Oh, okay.
Dang, I've been playing a long time.
Oh, gosh.
This game is fine.
What is this one?
Constructing mass of vines that bind cards and deal three
damage.
Ew.
I can't do anything, though.
Kind of stuck.
Okay.
Turn it down just a tad.
That was great, but also didn't help.
What are you gonna do?
You're gonna...
Seven damage!
Okay.
Yikes.
Oh gosh.
We'll clear that.
this one maybe oh okay
oh of course i use it oh my gosh i should have i should have
i should have paid attention and i didn't i didn't pay
attention depletes your mana by 12 i don't even have 12.
then i shouldn't use this we'll do this instead
Oh gosh!
So rude.
She's gonna swipe seven damage from me.
I can't, I can't use this!
I don't,
I couldn't do anything except that, I think.
Three damage, okay.
We can at least, we can at least do something about that.
that a little bit and we can get more okay okay um king
three damage could be better could be worse yeah this one's
a real damage race it is right
oh my gosh ah wait what is this increases health by 10 are
you kidding me right now by 10 is so much oh think we're
gonna win this one this one's crazy are we for real and then
you're gonna do another seven damage to me insane insane oh
i read that as defense okay never mind uh maybe i should
have gone for this one but it's fine maybe if i die i die
ass queen give me nothing oh
wow she's back to where i got her before the heal card i
can't use it i need 10 mana i only have nine wait what is
this one oh never mind i'm about to have zero
you and i can't even do anything this turn.
No, I countered though.
That was cool.
We love that.
Yeah, we're cooked.
My eyes!
Let me...
I wonder if I should...
Actually, let's buy this, the revived gem.
Because I think it will be most useful in this battle.
Let me throw It's starting to hurt.
Ah!
Does it have no water?
I only have coffee.
Which I should not be drinking at midnight.
Okay.
Wait.
I'll do it.
This is a perfect time to...
Was she gonna do the vines first?
So we'll do this.
I'm not...
That's all I...
Oh, that's not all I can do.
Okay.
And it hurts her.
Go get water if I want to drink it.
Which I could go get it in a second.
I'm just so into this.
She's gonna swipe me!
I got one health back.
Ouch.
No.
Okay, I do have some moves.
Not enough!
Oh shoot, I should have saved it.
Oh, that's not bad.
She's gonna swipe me, at least I'll save two.
And then we'll do this.
Oh, I countered the RSM.
Delay.
her.
And then enter.
Then we'll delay her again.
So we can at least...
Ugh.
This will open up more, but we don't have any.
Take that hag down!
Yeah!
Oh, yes.
Well, if we do this, it'll open this up, and then we could
do this and hope and pray.
Okay.
Nothing.
No.
Okay, this is fine.
Ish.
It's not fine.
This is winnable now.
It's winnable.
Oh!
I didn't even realize that she was about dead.
Okay.
Wait.
Remove all playable cards with the same suit as the target
card.
Yippee!
The hag retreats shrieking in pain as she clutches her
skull.
Oh, I got a crit, that's why.
But the cruncher cry is muffled as her mouth and eyes are
engulfed in a burst of flora.
You turn your attention back towards the door.
You try to open it, but it resists.
There appears to be no locking mechanism, however.
It must be bound by some form of magic.
Oh, okay.
What do we got going on again?
Give you an extra undue!
A buy.
Adds an extra Joker slot.
Another buy.
Look at...
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm so beautiful.
But dazzle my hand.
We're playing?
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, Emily.
So I tracked down the legend about one of the artifacts that
Creepy... Creepy... Creepy Keeper Cult Kept.
Why is it a tongue twister in my game?
Funnily enough, it's a demonic deck of cards they call the
Forbidden Game.
Said to contain the trapped soul of an ancient demon named
Bellatro.
Supposedly, if you play it and win, you die.
Sucks to be good at cards.
Not this, but...
So if I beat the game, I die.
Wait.
Oh, no wonder that reviewer didn't die because of the bug.
I was going to say.
This really suck at card games, I guess.
Idiot loser.
I'll win.
I'd win.
And I will win.
No!
Oh,
so Little Timmy actually won.
You're right!
Little Timmy is a gamer!
Oh my gosh, I always believed in my son.
Oh.
Okay, we need more diamonds.
Yeah, more diamonds, more diamonds.
Okay.
This feels like traditional solitaire the way it's set up,
you know?
Yay!
Back from visiting the boss, how goes it?
We're winning, we're winning!
I think?
I think we're winning.
Feels like we're winning, no?
Oh yeah, we're winning, we're winning.
Oh, Minky Sweep, Minky Sweep!
I think?
It did not come down to it, though.
What's this one do again?
Oh, yeah.
I didn't realize.
I did it again.
Yay!
Club Dungeon!
and complete the Cloud Dungeon!
At last, you managed to break the door spell.
It swings open.
As you step within, you observe a long dark tunnel lined
with luminous diamonds and held up by a haphazard support
beams.
Mines are in the mines!
Echoes of deep chanting voices bound off the chasm walls.
You venture deeper into the mine.
The chanting grows louder.
The diamonds seem to blaze brighter with every word and
tone.
Cool, cool, cool, cool!
Pairing around a crate, you see them.
A group of roped figures on their knees, all chanting in
unison.
In the center, a statuesque man towers over the others,
leading them in concert.
Okay, I join too.
They're gonna be like, no, you have no shoes.
And you have no clothes.
Behind the group, you spot a door.
Silently, carefully, you journey towards it.
But!
This will be for another time.
How's our stats?
Most damage blocked is six.
That's pretty good.
Total cards played.
1093!
Total gems purchased.
17 out of 29.
Total jokers unlocked.
It's 15 out of 23.
Okay.
Almost there.
Yay!
Yippee, biggest multiplier, zero.
Oh, that's kind of sad.
But max overkill is six?
I feel like I've done more than six.
Come on.
I can't believe how hooked you got.
I was kind of worried that like maybe, you know, sometimes
these games, they really either click with you or they don't
at all, you know what I mean?
So I was kind of worried.
I was like, Oh, what if I, like, I'm stupid at the game and
I just don't understand how it works, but I feel like I got
it pretty easy.
You had a 15, but you insta-killed them.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
I did insta-kill them before it went off.
And our sister is, like, going crazy on the research.
So I'm really interested to see how this ends.
Bravo!
You showed those giant scary monsters, hedge rows,
staircases, who's the boss?
the boss boss too help good health lots of rust and happy
dreams are in the cards for you tonight thank you for the
stream thank you torgo thank you turns out you are a genius
yes praise me more praise me more
i'm a genius i'm a genius i'm a genius i yeah a little timmy
died but i'll i won't die and also be better.
Just don't gouge your eyes out, stupid, stupid kid.
Would you also jump off a bridge if they told you to?
If the cult said, hey, now you beat the game.
To beat the game in real life, you have to jump off a
bridge.
To beat the game in real life, you have to gouge your eyes
out.
Now I'm not going to do that.
I'm built different.
Yeah!
Yeah, dummy.
Jinusou, cuteo, sweeto.
it's getting freaky for real i'd jump if you said so minto
don't say that what's wrong with you don't say that thanks
for the fun stream minto tensai thank you guys i hope you
had fun with the game i will see you later i'm gonna go
drink water oh too mito it's a mito to meeto thank you
everybody thank you so much have a good day have a good
night you when i see you next yes yes yes yeah i'm thirsty i
mean i'm thirsty what if this was my streaming pc though how
high fake me thank you number one number number one genius
number one ghost number one made bye bye bye Bye bye